Hey friends, it's Jillian from the teach me how to add all podcast if like me you're looking to travel more this year and make Some extra income on the side. This one is for you We've teamed up with Airbnb to share more about how to be an Airbnb host because you could be sitting in the perfect Airbnb spot right now if you have a spare bedroom Which also side note is such a fun way to meet new people from around the world if you're hosting them Why not make some extra money off of it? Or if you're always traveling like I am It's so easy to just Airbnb your whole place I was out of town for four months out of the year last year with a vacant condo
Just sitting there not being used and I've realized how easy it would be to make extra money in the side to cover all of My travel costs when I'm away just by becoming an Airbnb host when I'm traveling the world I almost exclusively stay in Airbnb's because I like having access to a kitchen Feeling like I'm at home when I'm traveling having all the stuff that you would normally have when you're at home And I love the local recommendation guides that a lot of hosts provide So you can just get to know the area that you're visiting from someone who's actually lived in it I just used Airbnb actually into loom to stay at truly the most luxurious penthouse loft I have I've ever seen it was
Such a vibe the aesthetic was incredible The service was fantastic and I loved the privacy of it Airbnb is such a smart way to use what you already have to generate more income Whether you're saving for a wedding or a big trip somewhere or just trying to cover bills and possibly bump up your income Your home might be worth more than you think so find out how much at Airbnb.ca Slash host Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents if you feel at any time you need support Please contact your local crisis center for suggested phone numbers for confidential support
Please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website As Her 21st birthday approached in 2008 Britt Catherine May Lapthorn asked her parents for just one present The biggest travel backpack she could carry Britt was planning a solo backpacking trip through Europe for the middle of the year Taking the time off to explore the world do a little soul-searching and find inspiration for her future career The RMIT University student had been working hard at completing her international business degree
But was looking forward to spending some time away from the books After deferring a semester of her studies Britt was scheduled to fly out of her home city of Melbourne, Victoria in late June 2008 Embarking on a four-month solo backpacking trek that would take her through multiple countries Before returning home to Australia in mid-October It came as absolutely no surprise to those who knew Britt Lapthorn that she had itchy feet and was seeking overseas adventure Her passport read like an explorer's autobiography Each stamp representing a wealth of stories and experiences she had earned around the world
When Britt was eight years old her family lived in China and by age 10 Britt was bartering with locals in Beijing's markets When she was 12 she was navigating the ancient roads of Uzbekistan By her early 20s Britt Lapthorn had stepped foot on almost every continent on the planet Having traveled more in her 20 years than most would in a lifetime She made it her mission to visit a new overseas destination every year Despite her wonderlust and thirst for adventure Britt loved coming back home to Australia She lived with her parents Dale and Elka in the Victorian suburb of Eden Park
A picturesque semi-rural township 45 kilometers north of Melbourne City At the end of each one of her trips Britt would collate all the knick-knacks and photographs she had collected along the way and display them on a pinboard in her bedroom The board was covered with photos of Britt with friends and landmarks and with badges Tickets pins lanyards and key rings Each item no matter how ordinary to others was a treasure Britt cherished When she was home Britt preferred a low-key relaxed lifestyle She relished kicking her shoes off and getting into her comfiest old dressing gown and slippers
Settling in for a night on the couch watching television with her mom The mother and daughter bonded over their passion for music and books and loved indulging their shared sweet tooth together To Britt family was the most important thing. It was the foundation of her life She looked forward to family gatherings where she took great pleasure in setting the dining table with the lapdorn's best crockery glassware and candles Christmas was her favorite holiday and her family celebrated in line with the traditions of her mother's German heritage On Christmas Eve the lapdorns would share a delicious dinner and exchange presents thereafter Dessert was Britt's favorite course. She especially loved rich cheesecakes with berries the more decadent the better
The tomboy throughout her childhood Britt grew up playing with her older brother Darren and his friends She'd ride as a passenger on Darren's pee-wee bike an oversized helmet balanced on her head and a gumboos hanging off her feet As Britt entered adolescence she became more interested in the typical teenage girl fascinations clothes makeup and perfume By the time Britt got her driver's license Her parents hardly saw her as she was always off on her own independent adventures in the family's old Saab car
Despite trusting their daughter wholeheartedly Dale and Elka would lay awake at night until they heard the Saab coming down the driveway Finding peace only when they knew their daughter was home safe Britt was an intelligent friendly and loving young woman and it was her spark for life that charmed her boyfriend Simon Imberger He fully supported his girlfriend's free spirit referring to her as trip thorn after her love for travel As the departure date for Britt's european backpacking adventure approached She spent night after night on her computer researching all the places she wanted to visit Although she had a general idea of her itinerary. She wanted the finer details to be spontaneous and unpredictable
She planned to keep friends and family back home updated through her facebook page Which she used as a travel log and virtual gallery littered with status updates quirky stories and candid photos of her life abroad As such aside from her passport her most valued travel companion was her cannon power shot g9 camera Although they would miss their daughter as she jet set it across the globe Britt's parents were proud of the headstrong independent ambitious woman their little girl had grown up to be Dale and Elka looked forward to reuniting with her daughter in paris to celebrate her 21st birthday the month after her departure Before Britt headed off Dale and Elka presented her with an early birthday present It was the one thing she had been asking them for
An olive and black colored black wolf brand backpack The biggest one she could carry In Late june 2008 equipped with her trusty camera brand new backpack and $5,000 in spending money Britt lapdorn departed melbourne for europe She arrived in dotman to germany An industrial yet cosmopolitan city in the country's northwest where her 25 year old brother darin was living at the time Darin was a professional cyclist who had been recruited by a german team after winning the 2007 australian road race championships
The two lapdorn siblings had always been close Britt followed in her brother's footsteps They both attended kilmore international school in their teens and later were both accepted into rmit university in melbourne to study business The motivation and commitment his younger sister showed towards her studies was something darin greatly admired While his textbooks remained unopened until the evening before an exam Brits were well-worn bent and doggie-ed from constant use She spoke of one day opening a spa business with several other friends But hadn't yet decided what she wanted to do after graduating from university
No matter what career path brit decided to follow Darin had no doubt his sister was going to be incredibly successful By early july brit traveled to paris where she met up with her parents who had journeyed over to celebrate her upcoming 21st birthday The family spent the lead up to brit's birthday experiencing the city of lights Walking the beautiful streets and marvelling over the striking parisian architecture and history brit and delca were left to explore the louvre museum together Walking arm in arm through the grand gallery admiring the famous work of the great artists
Upon observing the Mona Lisa they pinched themselves with excitement brit loved films and was excited to see firsthand the masterpiece featured in the blockbuster movie the da Vinci code The pair were sowing war of the sheer grandeur of the museum that they temporarily got lost in the seemingly endless network of rooms and displays On july 13 the lap thorn celebrated brit's 21st birthday at a restaurant near the arctic triomphe A photograph captured brit and delca in a warm embrace at an alfresco table Their contentedness evident on their smiling faces The experience couldn't have been more perfect They all described it as just happiness
After paris brit escorted her parents to germany where the close knit family of four stayed in darin's small apartment With limited space they all slept on the couch Whilst brit and her mother lay head to toe in a single bed The pair found it rather humorous with elka telling her daughter quote This might sound corny brit, but this feels really special to feel your body next to mine Because it may not happen again By late july dale and elka lap thorn had farewell to their two children Although it was only temporary as they'd be seeing brit again in just a few months time
When she returned home to melbourne on october 15 By august brit's solo backpacking journey had commenced and she made her way east to poland It was easy for the friendly and talkative brit lap thorn to make friends on the road It was in poland where she met a fellow ozzie backpacker named tara reynolds And the two enjoyed the sights together before brit set out for her next destination the check republic hungary and austria followed soon after Throughout her trip brit kept friends and family in the loop of her travels by periodically posting updates on her facebook page Although she had a mobile phone with her her social media site was a much more affordable way to keep in touch on her type budget
brit's facebook profile was littered with vibrant photographs and excited status updates full of exclamation marks As she shared her travel plans and foreign experiences Dozens of photos captured the backpacker all smiles as she sampled new foods Soaked up the views of sprawling cities and partied with new friends she met along the way On september 5 brit made the 300 kilometer journey south from vienna to slovenia Where she kayaked and swam in the pristine blue waters of lake bled in the julian alps It was the highlight of her trip so far brit logged into her facebook account and posted a status update that read
brit is in the best place she's seen in a while On september 9 after lapping up a couple more days in slovenia brit made her way east to the Croatian capital of zagreb A bustling city celebrated for its 18th and 19th century austro-hungarian architecture On september 11 she cut across the border into sarajevo bosnia Where she sent her boyfriend simon imburger a message to let him know she had arrived safely Hey just arrived in sarajevo So tired took so long to get here on a dodgy scary train
But it was really okay Just glad i made it During a long bus ride from sarajevo to the scenic bosnian city of mostar brit met a fellow young female backpacker who shared her sense of adventure A canadian named chris nose worthy The two immediately hit it off and were thrilled to discover they were booked into the same hostel in mostar becoming instant travel buddies Chris and brit explored mostar's medieval streets together
And after sampling some exotic local cuisine brit logged into facebook and posted Drinking yummy coffee and never eating brains again She loved the ancient city its location on the noretva river and its iconic 16th century bridge providing a fairy tale like atmosphere In an online message to a uniferant back home brit described mostar as one of the best places she had ever visited She expressed her wish to stay in mostar for a few more weeks, but had to keep moving as southern italy beckoned her It was whilst in mostar that brit met brad her fellow traveler from her home city of melbourne As the pair exchanged travel stories and upcoming plans brit mentioned that the Croatian coast was her next destination Having made the coastal trip before brad warned brit that his experience hadn't been entirely positive
He had found the locals to be quite unwelcoming and inhospitable and had also heard some horror stories from other travelers about their time there One young woman who ventured to a Croatian island had apparently woken up in a stranger's car With absolutely no recollection of how she had gotten there Brit took brad's warning seriously though she wasn't deterred by them Having traveled constantly throughout her life brit was not unfamiliar with the dangers presented to solo female travelers in foreign lands She told brad about one of her own unnerving experiences During a train ride through the balkans strangers kept coming into her carriage making her feel unsafe Brad could tell brit was a smart switched on traveler and he was confident the girl could hold her own
On september 15 brit ventured out on a hot rainy day trip to Croatia's Dalmatian coast A picturesque narrow shoreline framing the Adriatic Sea After yet another unforgettable day brit posted a status update on facebook, which read Brit had the best day Jumping off cliffs into water swimming under waterfalls and getting soaked in the rain Upon learning from a friend that the Croatian coast was an ideal gateway to southern Italy Brit made the Croatian seaside city of Dubrovnik her next destination Her new friend and travel buddy canadian backpacker chris nosworthy also had the location on her itinerary
On september 15 brit ventured out on a hot rainy day trip to Croatia's Dalmatian coast A picturesque narrow shoreline framing the Adriatic Sea After yet another unforgettable day brit posted a status update on facebook, which read Brit had the best day Jumping off cliffs into water swimming under waterfalls and getting soaked in the rain Upon learning from a friend that the Croatian coast was an ideal gateway to southern Italy Brit the Croatian seaside city of Dubrovnik her next destination Her new friend and travel buddy canadian backpacker chris nosworthy also had the location on her itinerary
As she looked forward to scuba diving in the clear and tranquil waters of the Adriatic Sea The pair decided to travel together and were joined by Dominic Dabrowiewski a polish american backpacker They had met at their hostel in Mostar On the morning of september 16 As brit lapped the one's friends and family logged into their facebook accounts They were greeted with a status update from the traveler revealing her next destination Who read Off to Dubrovnik Croatia
Located on the southern coast of Croatia lies the port city of Dubrovnik A stunning medieval town nicknamed the pearl of the Adriatic The city has earned a status as a UNESCO world heritage listed site for its perfectly preserved renaissance architecture Which includes a centuries old stone wall encircling the Dubrovnik central hub that has withstood foreign empires earthquakes and invaders There are only two entrances into the walled city Leading into a dense maze of cobblestone streets lined with a myriad of shops restaurants and bars Although it's a relatively small quiet city with a population of just over 40 000
Dubrovnik has become Croatia's most visited city The local economy depends heavily on the millions of tourists who visit throughout the year Drawn to the pristine blue waters of the Adriatic sea picturesque old town and surrounding rugged limestone mountains Despite being an expensive place to visit Dubrovnik has become a popular hotspot for backpackers due to its reputation as a safe laid-back destination which provides seafaring access to some of europe's other standout coastal towns Britlapthorn arrived to Dubrovnik accompanied by her travel companions Chris knows worthy and Dominic Dabrovievsky
The trio checked in to the Dubrovnik backpackers club a multi-story hostel perched on a hill in the newer part of the city The small yet vibrant hostel was made up of three guest rooms containing two sets of bunk beds each And included all the quintessential backpacker facilities like a communal kitchen and recreation room with internet access a projector screen and a selection of DVDs The Dubrovnik backpackers club was privately run by the local Perkovich family who lived on site in the ground floor apartment to oversee the hostel's daily operations As Brit and her travel partners checked in, London backpacker Gareth Hopkins arrived at the hostel and struck up a conversation with the group They all hit it off and two hours later the new arrivals headed to the harbourside where they enjoyed a seafood meal together at a restaurant
before embracing Dubrovnik's nightlife The following day, September 17, 2008, Brit, Chris, Dominic and Gareth spent the day exploring Dubrovnik's nightlife exploring Dubrovnik's old quarter, strolling through the narrow streets and hanging out at a cafe in one of the sunlit squares Later that day, Chris knows worthy parted ways with the group to attend a scuba diving course on a nearby island But she and Brit planned to meet up again in a few weeks time to continue their journey together to the Croatian city of Split where Brit had plans to take a transit ferry west to Italy Brit was in good spirits as the two said their goodbyes, excited about their upcoming adventures That evening while hanging out in the hostel, Brit made a quick Facebook post advising everyone back home that she had made it safely to Dubrovnik
That night, the Dubrovnik Backpackers Club was a hive of activity as guests crowded in the small kitchen space to cook and share dinner Guests were from a melting pot of nationalities and ranged in ages from 20 to 30 Mostly solo travelers who intended to stay in Dubrovnik for a short while before departing for their next destination in a day or two's time After dinner, the enthusiastic group had some drinks and hung out in the hostel's recreation room At around midnight, they were no closer to settling down for the night And to their antics drew the attention of the hostel owners who requested they keep the noise to a minimum Still full of energy and wanting to socialize, a suggestion was made for the group to head out on the town They had heard the local hotspot for backpackers was a lively nightclub called Club Fuego
And although it was a wednesday night, the club was operating outside of its usual weekend hours to cater to the busy tourist season The well-established and popular latin themed nightclub had been a backpackers haunt since 2001 Having earned a positive reputation for its professional staff and affordable prices Opened from 11 p.m. Until 6 a.m. The club was the perfect place for late night revelers Britlapthorn agreed to go check it out as did fellow Australians David Barberlay, Jason Levy and Lydia Hambrook And the two men Brit had befriended over the previous days Dominic Dabrowiecki and Gareth Hopkins They were also joined by portuguese backpackers Marina Moreira and Gil Yermo Augusto After getting ready the backpackers boarded a local bus to make the 3.8 kilometer journey to the nightclub
At 12.38 a.m. They arrived at Club Fuego Located near the main entrance of Dabrovnik's old town a stone's throw from the town's historic port section Deon assuming two-story building was marked by a large black sign depicting the figure of a dancing female Her pink dress billowing as she raised her arms in the air A banner painted across the front of the building displayed the words Latino club in bold yellow lettering And mainstream dance music thumped from within Club Fuego's interior was dark with dim lighting throughout except for the bright neon lights flickering over the massive dance floor There were crowds of people everywhere on both levels of the building with around 200 other young clubgoers
Surrounding the five different bars milling around the standing tables and spilling across the dance floor When Brit and her companions entered it wasn't long before they became separated through the crowds The following morning of thursday september 18 2008 A backpacker named Maria who was sharing a dorm room with Britlapthorn at the Dabrovnik backpackers club hostel Worked to find the Australian girls bed neat and unoccupied as though it hadn't been slept in overnight Maria had not attended club Fuego with the rest of the group the night prior and assumed Brit must have had a big night and was still out partying Despite Brit being the only clubgoer unaccounted for nothing about the behavior of the others in the hostel indicated they were concerned about her absence Therefore Maria didn't think there was anything to worry about
When night time descended Britlapthorn had still not reappeared at the hostel and her personal belongings including her olive and black black wolf backpack Remained untouched in her dorm room As the other guests who had attended club Fuego in the early hours of september 18 pulled their recollections together They determined that the last known sighting of Brit was inside the club at approximately 3 30 a.m. None of them had seen Brit leave Given Brit's approachable and talkative nature They considered the unnerving possibility that she might have accepted a lift home from an ill-intentioned local
When night time descended Britlapthorn had still not reappeared at the hostel and her personal belongings including her olive and black black wolf backpack Reached untouched in her dorm room As the other guests who had attended club Fuego in the early hours of september 18 pulled their recollections together They determined that the last known sighting of Brit was inside the club at approximately 3 30 a.m. None of them had seen Brit leave Given Brit's approachable and talkative nature They considered the unnerving possibility that she might have accepted a lift home from an ill-intentioned local
All ran into danger while walking through the dark unfamiliar streets alone When they tried calling Brit's mobile phone it rang out and went unanswered and eventually it stopped ringing altogether The backpackers determined it was highly unlikely that Brit had moved on to her next travel destination As her Australian passport was securely locked away in the hostel safe Lydia Handbrook, an Australian who had attended club Fuego became increasingly concerned when Brit still had not reappeared the following day of Friday september 19 After a day outside seeing After a day outside seeing Lydia returned to the hostel and noticed that Brit's belongings had been moved about Relieved she assumed her friend had finally returned
However, she soon found out Brit's things had simply been shifted aside whilst the dorm room was being cleaned Brit lap thorns whereabouts remained a mystery By the second night the backpackers discussed their next steps They each had plans to travel onwards from Dubrovnik, but it didn't feel right to just up and leave without knowing Brit was safe They decided to inform the hostel owners of Brit's disappearance Hoping they would know what to do When the Perkovich family were informed that one of their guests had failed to return home two nights in a row They were immediately worried and promised to keep an eye out for Brit
At 2 a.m. Hostel owner Milka Perkovich arose to check if Brit was in her bed, but it was still empty Milka expressed her increasing anxieties about Brit to her 33 year old son Evita He dismissed his mother's concerns telling her We will see in the morning. They're just young crazy kids But the next morning there was still no sign of Brit Chris knows worthy Brit's Canadian travel companion who was scheduled to meet up with Brit in a few weeks time Logged into her email account and was shocked to find an email from mutual travel friend Dominic Dabrovetsky Notifying her that Brit hadn't returned to the hostel after a night out
Dominic's email read She doesn't seem like the kind of girl to just go home with some dude I'm really worried and desperately racking my brains to see if I can remember who she was with But so far no luck Please get back to me Dominic's email triggered immediate alarm bells for Chris She tried calling Brit's mobile phone multiple times, but it was switched off So she proceeded to send private messages to Brit's facebook account
Desperately hoping for a response When her messages remained unanswered a panicked Chris emailed Dominic looking for an update writing Has she still not been found? Man, I hope she's met back up with you guys by this point Dominic replied I'm crossing my fingers that just some weird shit happened and she's okay I'll keep you updated
Concerned guests at the Dabrovnik Backpackers Club rifled through Brit's backpack looking for information to contact her family back in Australia When they couldn't find anything they placed a phone call to the Australian embassy in Croatia and explained the situation An embassy official made numerous calls including to Dabrovnik law enforcement However, local police were hesitant to act as young tourists, especially Australians, were known to party hard in Dabrovnik They suspected Brit was just another boozy backpacker on a bender who'd stumbled back to her hostel eventually nursing a hangover The embassy official urged the Dabrovnik police to launch an inquiry into Brit Lapthorn's disappearance But their request was denied Brit Lapthorn's typically active Facebook feed had gone radio silent
Messages from friends encouraging her to keep them in the loop of her plans when ignored Back in Australia Brit's boyfriend Simon Inburger had not heard from his traveling girlfriend So on September 21 Simon sent Brit a message which read Hey B hope Dubtown's still rocking and to the bugs aren't as big Keep laughing and trip thorn Brit's lack of contact had been noticed by her parents as her regular calls home had also stopped The last time the Lapthorns had spoken to their daughter was a few days prior to her arrival in Dabrovnik when she phoned home to wish her father a happy birthday They had teased her because the phone call was a day late
But Brit had playfully brushed off their friendly taunts saying Mum I've been traveling On September 22 Elka Lapthorn wrote a message on her daughter's Facebook page hoping to prompt a reply typing Hi Brit missing your travel log Meanwhile the Lapthorns were completely unaware that their daughter had disappeared from a Dabrovnik nightclub days earlier It wasn't until September 24 when Brit Lapthorn had been unaccounted for for a week That the local Dabrovnik police were finally willing to formally consider her a missing person and initiate an investigation
They gave the Department of Foreign Affairs and Trade permission to inform Brit's family in Australia Distressed parents Dale and Elka Lapthorn were devastated that they hadn't been informed of their daughter's disappearance sooner Dale Lapthorn quote I'm disappointed that the Australian Embassy knew about this on September 19 and it took them until September 24 for us to be notified It's horrific They were also shocked to learn that nothing had been done to find Brit during the first 72 hours of her disappearance Considered the most crucial time frame in solving a missing person case The odds of finding the person safe and well dramatically decreased thereafter
Dale and Elka feared their daughter had met with foul play Brit was spontaneous and adventurous, but also clever and self-aware Far from the flaky naive young traveler Dabrovnik police perceived her to be With Brit's family now involved a missing person report was issued by Victoria police And faxed through to the Australian federal police It featured a picture of Brit Lapthorn Her distinctive blonde bob haircut with a fringe framed her hazel eyes and a trademark beaming smile The report described her as a white 21 year old female
152 centimetres tall weighing 47 kilograms with a light olive complexion and a stud nose piercing Her last known whereabouts were listed as club Fuego in Dabrovnik with her attire described as summer clothing with black leggings The report characterized Brit as well-travelled, worldly, sensible, friendly and talkative Anyone with information was urged to contact Elka Lapthorn or the Department of Foreign Affairs and Trade In the Dabrovnik Backpackers Club Hostel, Brit's cherished 21st birthday present, her olive and green black wolf backpack Had been placed on a chair in the lobby alongside a vase of red and white roses left by well-wishers The only items noted as missing were her wallet containing a small amount of cash and her beloved cannon power shot G9 camera Items that was believed she took with her to club Fuego
Her bank accounts, passport and other travel documents had not been accessed since her disappearance Tara Reynolds who had met Brit in Poland managed a website with over 15,000 members dedicated to tracing the movements of global travellers Upon learning of Brit's disappearance Upon learning of Brit's disappearance Tara created an online group to help find Brit writing All we can do is spread awareness in the hope that someone somewhere was around on that fateful night and may have seen her We are just hoping for clues and waiting for now I miss Brit terribly especially since all my travel photos are constant reminders of such a horrific thing to happen to such a beautiful soul
自她失踪以来，她的银行账户、护照和其他旅行证件都没有被登录或使用过。塔拉·雷诺兹（Tara Reynolds）曾在波兰见过布里，她管理着一个拥有15,000多名成员的网站，专门追踪全球旅行者的动向。得知布里失踪后，塔拉创建了一个在线群组来帮助寻找布里，并写道：“我们能做的就是传播消息，希望某个地方、某个当时在那决定性夜晚的人可能见过她。我们现在只能祈求线索，静静等待。我非常想念布里，尤其是当看到所有旅行照片时，它们都在不断提醒我，如此可怕的事竟然发生在一个如此美丽的灵魂身上。”
It isn't me. I worry about it's her family I pray for her safe return to them We are posting messages in travel forums contacting hostels and doing everything we can on the internet that we can possibly do The outreach for help in finding Brit Lapthorn spread far beyond the stone walls of Dubrovnik's medieval city Once the news that an Australian national was missing in a foreign country made its way down under The Australian media rallied to raise awareness of the mounting search for Brit Dozens of Australian reporters and journalists arrived to Dubrovnik eager to cover the story That was a real-life manifestation of fears straight out of popular Hollywood movies like Hostel and Taken
“不是我。我担心的是她的家人，我祈祷她能平安回到他们身边。”我们在旅游论坛上发帖，联系青年旅舍，并在互联网上尽我们所能做的一切。寻找布里·拉普索恩（Brit Lapthorn）的呼吁远远超出了杜布罗夫尼克中世纪古城的石墙。一旦澳大利亚公民在国外失踪的消息传回国内，澳大利亚媒体便群起响应，呼吁大家关注对布里不断扩大的搜寻工作。数十名澳大利亚记者和新闻工作者抵达杜布罗夫尼克，渴望报道这个故事。这就像是好莱坞热门电影《人皮客栈》和《飓风营救》中的恐惧在现实生活中的上演。
In Taken the protagonist's daughter is abducted whilst traveling in France for the sole purpose of being sold on to the sex trade Mimicking a very real problem that plagues certain parts of the world The illegal trafficking of persons for sex remains an ongoing issue in many southeastern European countries including Croatia As rumours circled that Brit may have fallen prey to this fate Dale Lapthorn stated Quite honestly, that would be a good outcome because I want my daughter back alive The overwhelming Australian media presence in the otherwise quiet and sleepy coastal city rattled the local population Dubrovnik was well regarded for its low crime rate and serious crimes were considered incredibly rare
在《飓风营救》中，主角的女儿在法国旅行时遭到绑架，其唯一目的就是被卖到性交易市场。这模仿了困扰世界某些地区的真实问题，女性的非法性交易在包括克罗地亚在内的许多东南部欧洲国家依然是一个持续存在的问题。随着关于布里可能遭遇这种命运的传言四起，戴尔·拉普索恩（Dale Lapthorn）表示：“坦白说，那倒算是个好结果，因为我希望女儿活着回来。”澳大利亚媒体在原本宁静慵懒的海滨城市的大举出现，让当地居民感到不安。杜布罗夫尼克一直以低犯罪率著称，严重犯罪被认为极其罕见。
Unlike other cities popular with budget backpackers that were often associated with poverty and lawlessness Dubrovnik was a safe and affluent city, protected and insulated within its defiance stone walls The Lapthorns believed Dubrovnik's low risk reputation may have caused Brit to let her guard down and relinquish her usual cautious mindset While also being to blame for the hesitancy of the local police to take her disappearance seriously Darren Lapthorn, quote British street smart and a seasoned traveler, but she came to Dubrovnik really relaxed She was at the point where she might have been a bit more complacent about meeting people and I think someone could have seen that weakness
与其他常与贫困和无政府状态联系在一起、深受预算有限的背包客欢迎的城市不同，杜布罗夫尼克是一座安全而富裕的城市，在其防御性的石墙内受到保护和庇护。拉普索恩一家认为，杜布罗夫尼克低风险的声誉可能导致布里放松了警惕，放弃了她一贯谨慎的心态，这也是当地警方对她的失踪态度敷衍的原因之一。达伦·拉普索恩（Darren Lapthorn）评价说：“布里很有街头智慧，也是个经验丰富的旅行者，但她来到杜布罗夫尼克时真的放松了警惕。她当时可能对结识新朋友变得有点麻痹大意了，我想有人可能看出了这个弱点。”
The Dubrovnik police forces week-long delay in launching an investigation was heavily criticised in the Australian media As was the presumption by local police that Brit was just a foreign party girl who would reappear unharmed at any moment Brit's friends and family were quick to dispute this interpretation of Brit claiming she was far from the person police were painting her to be Those closest to Brit described her as a conservative drinker And although she enjoyed the occasional night out partying and socialising like most people in their 20s Her main focus was on experiencing all the world had to offer Her days abroad were not spent in hungover hazes But on energetic adventures as she covered large distances in short time frames and soaked up as many new experiences as she possibly could
杜布罗夫尼克警方在失踪一周后才展开调查，这在澳大利亚媒体中受到了严厉批评。当地警方甚至推测布里只是一个外国派对女孩，随时会安然无恙地再次出现，这种假设也同样遭到批评。布里的朋友和家人迅速反驳了这种对布里的解读，声称她绝不是警方所描绘的那种人。最亲近布里的人将她形容为一个保守的饮酒者。尽管她偶尔也会像大多数20多岁的年轻人一样外出聚会和社交，但她的主要重心是体验世界所能提供的一切。她在国外的日子不是在宿醉的迷糊中度过的，而是充满精力的冒险，她在短时间内跨越了很长的距离，尽可能多地吸收新的体验。
Brit's thirst for travel was not fueled by alcohol and a tendency for reckless behaviour She wanted to learn more about the world, its history and how people from different cultures lived To Dale, his daughter's willingness to visit places like Auschwitz was evidence of her strength of character and maturity Quote She wanted to understand suffering to see and really get a feeling for the places she was going In Bosnia, she said she wanted to understand what happened there When Brit's older brother Darren learned of his sister's disappearance He rushed from Germany to Croatia arriving in Dubrovnik to aid in the search
布里对旅行的渴望并非由酒精和鲁莽的行为倾向所驱动。她想要更多地了解这个世界、它的历史以及不同文化背景下的人们是如何生活的。对戴尔来说，他的女儿愿意参观奥斯威辛等地方，证明了她坚强的性格和成熟度。引用他的话说：“她想了解苦难，去看一看，并真正感受她所去过的地方。在波斯尼亚，她说她想了解那里发生了什么。”当布里的哥哥达伦得知妹妹失踪的消息时，他从德国赶往克罗地亚，抵达杜布罗夫尼克协助搜寻。
Upon arrival, he was shocked to discover that local police still weren't taking his sister's case seriously And overall were uncooperative and reluctant to help Police told Darren There has never been crime in Dubrovnik and there can never be crime in Dubrovnik When Darren inquired about the scope of their investigation Police said they had only managed to interview one backpacker who had been a guest at the Dubrovnik Backpackers Club at the same time as Brit The other guests had since moved on to other countries and Dubrovnik police refused to track them down Telling Darren that was outside of their jurisdiction
刚一抵达，他震惊地发现当地警方仍然没有认真对待他妹妹的案子，而且总的来说不合作、不愿提供帮助。警方对达伦说：“杜布罗夫尼克从来没有发生过犯罪，这里也绝不可能发生犯罪。”当达伦询问他们调查的范围时，警方表示他们只设法采访了一名背包客，该背包客在布里失踪时也是杜布罗夫尼克背包客俱乐部（Dubrovnik Backpackers Club）的客人。其他客人此后已经前往其他国家，而杜布罗夫尼克警方拒绝追踪他们，并告诉达伦这超出了他们的管辖范围。
Darren asked to view the CCTV footage recorded in the proximity of club Fuego at the time Brit was present There were seven security cameras located throughout the two-story nightclub building Including one in the entry foyer and another directly above the dance floor Police informed Darren that observing this footage would be impossible As a mysterious electrical fault had occurred on September 18 rendering all the club's interior cameras defective When Darren pressed the police for proof of this alleged blackout They changed their story and instead claimed a wiring issue had interfered with the performance of the cameras According to police the corrupted footage had been sent to a lab in an attempt to salvage it
达伦要求查看布里在场期间在Fuego俱乐部附近录制的闭路电视录像。这家两层的夜总会建筑内共有七个安全摄像头，包括一个在入口门厅，另一个直接在舞池上方。警方通知达伦，查看这些录像是不可能的，因为9月18日发生了一次神秘的电路故障，导致该俱乐部所有的室内摄像头都失灵了。当达伦向警方追问所谓停电的证据时，他们改变了说法，改口称是线路问题干扰了摄像头的性能。据警方称，受损的录像带已被送到实验室，试图进行修复。
But efforts were unsuccessful The vital images had been lost forever Nevertheless the police assured Darren that they had visited club Fuego and spoken to the club's bartenders and staff about Brit Darren later visited club Fuego only to discover that he had been misled As the nightclub staff revealed they hadn't been spoken to by anyone about his sister's disappearance Darren questioned the club employees himself, but given the time that it since lapsed their recollections of the early hours of September 18 were vague Hindering their efforts was the fact that the club's clientele were mostly young foreigners who didn't stay into brothels Which made remembering Brit from the hundreds of indistinguishable, ever-changing patrons incredibly difficult
但努力没有成功，至关重要的影像永远丢失了。尽管如此，警方还是向达伦保证，他们已经走访了Fuego俱乐部，并与俱乐部的酒保和员工谈过布里的事。达伦后来走访了Fuego俱乐部，却发现自己被误导了。因为夜总会员工透露，根本没有人就他妹妹的失踪找他们谈过话。达伦亲自盘问了俱乐部员工，但鉴于时间已经过去，他们对9月18日凌晨的记忆已经模糊不清。阻碍他们努力的一个事实是，该俱乐部的顾客大多是不在当地过夜的年轻外国人，这使得从数百个面目模糊、不断变化的顾客中记起布里变得异常困难。
There were faint recollections of Brit being served at the bar, but no worthwhile information was given that hinted at her whereabouts One thing was certain, if Brit was involved in some kind of altercation or incident the staff would remember As such occurrences were unusual at their establishment Club Fuego management disputed police claims that an electrical fault had rendered their cctv network ineffective Insisting that all seven of their internal security cameras were functioning during the early hours of September 18 They had previously handed all cctv equipment to police Including a hard drive that stored all recorded footage over the time period Brit Lapthorn was present And they had no reason to be able to find out what was going on
大家隐约记得布里曾在吧台被服务过，但并没有提供任何有价值的线索来暗示她的去向。有一点是肯定的，如果布里卷入了某种争执或事件，员工们一定会记得，因为此类事件在他们的场所很不寻常。Fuego俱乐部的管理层反驳了警方的说法，即电路故障导致他们的闭路电视网络失效，坚称他们所有的七个内部安全摄像头在9月18日凌晨都在正常工作。他们之前已将所有闭路电视设备交给了警方，包括一个存储了布里·拉普索恩在场期间所有录像的硬盘，而且他们没有理由查不出到底发生了什么。
They had no reason to believe the footage was defective A club Fuego bouncer recalled seeing someone fitting Brit's description leaving the club in the company of two males and five females This group had two cars between them and held a lengthy discussion as to who would travel in which vehicle It was clear to the bouncer that none of the women wanted to get in a car with the men But he didn't know who ended up travelling with who Mr. Had been within this group Darren believed she might have wound up in the car with the unknown men and that they may have been involved in her disappearance A close friend of Brit Lapthorn's told the Australian press quote
他们没有理由相信录像是有缺陷的。Fuego俱乐部的一名门卫回忆说，看到一个符合布里特征的人在两名男性和五名女性的陪伴下离开俱乐部。这群人之间有两辆车，并就谁坐哪辆车进行了长时间的讨论。门卫很清楚，这些女性中没有人想跟这些男人上同一辆车，但他不知道最后谁和谁一起走了。布里曾在这群人中间，达伦相信她可能最终上了那些陌生男人的车，他们可能与她的失踪有关。布里·拉普索恩的一位密友对澳大利亚媒体说：
I'll find it very unconvincing that Brit would have got into a car with somebody she didn't know If that's the case, there must have been some pressure Darren contacted his parents in Australia Frustrated and upset by the indifference of Dubrovnik law enforcement in helping find his sister The Lapthorns felt Dubrovnik police were being dismissive of their concerns and were treating their family with contempt Sharing his son's disappointment, they all Lapthorn told the Australian media Darren was extremely depressed after yesterday Seeing the police doing absolutely nothing
“我认为布里会和一个她不认识的人上车，这非常不可信。如果是这样的话，肯定施加了某种压力。”达伦给在澳大利亚的父母打了电话，对杜布罗夫尼克执法部门在协助寻找他妹妹方面的冷漠感到沮丧和难过。拉普索恩一家觉得杜布罗夫尼克警方对他们的担忧不屑一顾，对他们的家庭表现出蔑视。全家人都对儿子的失望感同身受，戴尔·拉普索恩告诉澳大利亚媒体，达伦在看到警方无所作为后，昨天感到极度沮丧。
Obviously telling lies, lies, lies And just hoping it would go away In a Facebook post, Elka Lapthorn pleaded The police are doing nothing We are beyond grief They have been given so much information and are doing nothing with it Please, don't be so angry Please all locals in Dubrovnik help us
显然是在撒谎、撒谎、撒谎，只是希望事情能自己过去。埃尔卡·拉普索恩（Elka Lapthorn）在脸书的一篇帖子里恳求道：“警察什么也没做。我们悲痛欲绝。他们得到了这么多的信息，却什么也没做。求求你们，别这么生气。求求杜布罗夫尼克的所有当地人帮帮我们。”
Help us Help us The criticism leveled against Dubrovnik authorities by Brit's loved ones was reported throughout the Croatian media Rather than prompting them to accelerate their investigation Dubrovnik police became tight lipped and refused to publicly divulge any more information in relation to the Brit Lapthorn case This left the Lapthorn family completely in the dark about how the search for their daughter was going or whether the investigation was proceeding at all Dubrovnik deputy police chief Ivan Kulkrika defended the police response to Brit's disappearance saying
帮帮我们，帮帮我们。布里所爱的人对杜布罗夫尼克当局的批评在克罗地亚各大媒体上都有报道。杜布罗夫尼克警方非但没有因此加快调查步伐，反而闭口不谈，拒绝公开透露任何与布里·拉普索恩案有关的更多信息。这使得拉普索恩一家对搜寻女儿的进展以及调查是否在进行一无所知。杜布罗夫尼克副警察局长伊万·库尔克里卡（Ivan Kulkrika）为警方对布里失踪的反应进行了辩护，称：
We are only human beings, but we are treating this case like it would be treated anywhere in the world I understand the worry of the family and I understand their criticism And I understand that it will force us to do more quality work But we really are doing the best job we can right now I can't tell you everything we have done, but this has not been a slow investigation Deputy police chief Kulkrika indicated he personally believed that Brit was still alive and would be found safe In 2008 there hadn't been a single murder reported in Dubrovnik or its surrounds Which the deputy attested to the fact that Dubrovnik was
“我们只是凡人，但我们对待这个案子的态度和世界上任何地方处理它的方式一样。我理解家人的担忧，也理解他们的批评。我也理解这会促使我们做更多高质量的工作。但我们现在确实在尽我们所能做到最好。我不能告诉你我们做过的一切，但这绝不是一项缓慢的调查。”副警察局长库尔克里卡表示，他个人相信布里仍然活着，并且会安全被找到。2008年，杜布罗夫尼克及其周边地区没有发生过一起谋杀案，副局长以此证明杜布罗夫尼克是……
quote The safest and most secure county in all of Croatia It wasn't just Croatian authorities who came under fire during the investigation into Brit Lapthorn's disappearance A visibly emotional Dale Lapthorn told Australian media that he and his wife had been contacted by the Australian federal police And asked to be mindful of Australia's relationship with Croatia when speaking publicly about their missing daughter The distressed couple were confounded when the AFP gave them a list of rules and undertakings to follow To ensure they wouldn't create tension between the two countries Dale Lapthorn quote
引用他的话说：“整个克罗地亚最安全、最稳妥的县。”在对布里·拉普索恩失踪案的调查中，遭到抨击的不仅仅是克罗地亚当局。一位情绪激动的戴尔·拉普索恩告诉澳大利亚媒体，他和妻子曾接到澳大利亚联邦警察（AFP）的电话，要求他们在公开谈论失踪女儿时注意澳大利亚与克罗地亚的关系。当AFP给这对心力交瘁的夫妇列出一份必须遵守的规则和承诺清单，以确保他们不会在两国之间制造紧张局势时，他们感到十分困惑。戴尔·拉普索恩引用：
I just got furious. We screamed at them on the phone We said you are public servants of Australia We are Australian citizens and we are not going to allow you to sacrifice my daughter's life for the sake of relations The outcry prompted a response from Australia's prime minister Kevin Rudd Prime minister Rudd empathised with the Lapthorns and other families who have had a loved one go missing overseas quote We take every case seriously because it could be our kids any day At any one time there are a million Australians offshore
“我当时气疯了。我们在电话里对他们尖叫，我们说你们是澳大利亚的公职人员。我们是澳大利亚公民，我们绝不允许你们为了两国关系而牺牲我女儿的生命。”这一强烈抗议引发了澳大利亚总理陆克文（Kevin Rudd）的回应。陆克文总理对拉普索恩一家以及其他亲人在海外失踪的家庭感同身受，他表示：“我们认真对待每一个案件，因为任何一天这都可能发生在我们自己的孩子身上。在任何特定时间，都有数百万澳大利亚人在海外。”
Our job is to do whatever we can to help families who find themselves in these horrible circumstances We will leave no stone unturned through the federal police Through our diplomats through consular officials Through our political contact with the government to do whatever we can do to assist in this really hard and difficult matter In Dubrovnik Darin Lapthorn was still seeking out any clue that might lead him to his sister He spent his days trawling the city streets plastering up missing person posters written in both English and Croatian along the way He logged on to Brits facebook account contacting the friends she had recently added or accepted to see what information they could provide Desperate for answers Darin visited a local clairvoyant seeking guidance as the where to focus his search
“我们的工作是尽一切所能帮助陷入这些可怕境况的家庭。我们将通过联邦警察、我们的外交官、领事官员，以及我们与政府的政治接触，不遗余力地做我们所能做的一切，来协助处理这个真正艰难而棘手的问题。”在杜布罗夫尼克，达伦·拉普索恩仍在寻找任何可能引导他找到妹妹的线索。他白天在城市街道上搜寻，沿途张贴用英文和克罗地亚文书写的失踪人员海报。他登录了布里的脸书账号，联系她最近添加或接受的朋友，看看他们能提供什么信息。渴望得到答案的达伦拜访了一位当地的灵媒，寻求指导，以便将搜寻重点放在哪里。
The clairvoyant revealed their mystic vision that Brits case would be solved when investigators located two men aged 21 to 31 years old The disappearance of Brit Lapthorn swept mythical dogma throughout Dubrovnik as the lack of information about her whereabouts led concerned residents to seek answers from higher powers Superstitious locals spoke darkly of the Croatian belief in the energy carried by Borah winds Dry, cool, northern gusts that sweep over the Vela bit mountain range out to the Adriatic Sea When Borah comes in, it drives debris further north and clears up the sky providing uninterrupted panoramic views from the mountains all the way to Italy Locals believed that when this change in weather finally occurred the mystery of Brit Lapthorn's disappearance would be solved Back in Australia, porch lights in Melbourne's Outer Suburban Streets were kept on as an expression of solidarity for Brit Lapthorn's safe return From the Lapthorn family home in Eden Park, her parents were doing their best to remain positive
灵媒透露了他们的神秘远见，即只要调查人员找到两名21至31岁的男子，布里的案件就会水落石出。布里的失踪在杜布罗夫尼克引发了神话般的教条，因为缺乏她下落的信息，导致焦虑的居民向更高的力量寻求答案。迷信的当地人暗地里谈论着克罗地亚关于博拉风（Borah winds）携带能量的信仰——这是横扫维拉比特山脉（Vela bit mountain range）直至亚得里亚海的干燥、凉爽的北部阵风。当博拉风吹来时，它会将残骸向北驱动，并清理天空，提供从山脉一直延伸到意大利的无遮挡全景视野。当地人相信，当天气终于发生这种变化时，布里·拉普索恩失踪之谜就会解开。在澳大利亚，墨尔本外郊街道上的门廊灯一直亮着，以表达对布里·拉普索恩安全归来的声援。在位于伊甸园公园（Eden Park）的拉普索恩家中，她的父母正尽最大努力保持积极。
Elka Lapthorn, quote Every morning I wake up and I feel there is still a glimmer of hope that Brit is still alive and that's what's keeping us going But the Lapthorn's hope was severely put to the test as time passed and still there were no answers as to what happened to their daughter They compiled a reward of 100,000 euros and offered to sell their house to boost the sum hoping it would compile the amount of money that Brit Lapthorn would be able to afford To boost the sum hoping it would compel someone to come forward with information that would lead to Brit Frustrated by the lack of progress in finding his missing daughter Dale Lapthorn boarded a flight to Croatia to conduct an investigation of his own joined by Brits boyfriend Simon
埃尔卡·拉普索恩引用：“每天早晨我醒来，都觉得仍然有一丝希望，那就是布里还活着，正是这一点在支撑着我们前行。”但随着时间流逝，关于女儿遭遇的事情依然没有答案，拉普索恩一家的希望受到了严峻的考验。他们凑集了10万欧元的悬赏金，并提出卖掉房子来增加这笔金额，希望能筹集到一笔能够吸引知情者站出来提供线索的巨额资金，从而找到布里。由于对寻找失踪女儿的进展感到沮丧，戴尔·拉普索恩登上了飞往克罗地亚的航班，在布里的男友西蒙（Simon）的陪同下，亲自展开调查。
On october 3 the power arrived to Dubrovnik with Dale vowing not to leave the city without his daughter Refusing to give up hope that Brit might still be alive quote I would like to think she's probably being held against her will I just couldn't imagine Other than for Darren and Brit. There's no purpose in living dare our everything Upon his arrival to Dubrovnik Dale was confronted by dramatic scenes as police helicopters flew over the surrounding mountains
10月3日，戴尔抵达杜布罗夫尼克，发誓不找到女儿绝不离开这座城市。他拒绝放弃布里可能还活着的希望，引用道：“我愿意认为她可能是在违背意愿的情况下被扣留的。我简直无法想象。除了达伦和布里，活着就没有别的目的了，达伦就是我们的一切。”一抵达杜布罗夫尼克，戴尔就面临着戏剧性的场面：警方直升机在周边山脉上空盘旋，
And officers with tracker dogs trawled outlying rural fields Police tape was strung up around key areas related to Brits disappearance Whilst forensic investigators searched that Dubrovnik backpackers club hostel It was far from the idle investigation Darren had anticipated and his spirits were lifted upon realizing police were taking efforts to find his daughter seriously However The actions of police were viewed with skepticism As some found it suspicious that law enforcement had suddenly ramped up their search efforts to coincide with Dale Lapthorn's presence in town
带着搜救犬的警官们搜寻着远郊的乡村田野。与布里失踪相关的关键区域周围拉起了警察警戒线，而法医调查人员则搜查了杜布罗夫尼克背包客俱乐部旅舍。这与达伦预期的懒散调查相去甚远，当他意识到警方正在努力认真寻找他的女儿时，他的精神受到了鼓舞。然而，警方的行动却受到了怀疑，因为有些人觉得奇怪：为什么执法部门突然加大搜寻力度，正好赶上戴尔·拉普索恩来到镇上？
The Brovnik officials were unwilling to explain why this intensive search hadn't occurred much earlier With local reporters suggesting police had finally succumbed to the pressure arising from the Australian media and Aussie citizens Critics believed the grand efforts displayed by Dubrovnik law enforcement were all for show And they hadn't really escalated the investigation into Brit Lapthorn's disappearance at all Dubrovnik police vehemently defended what they ensured was now a full-scale investigation into Brit Lapthorn's disappearance Adamant they were doing all they could to aid with the search Although admitting they had no leads in the case Dubrovnik deputy police chief Ivan Kukrika stood firm in his belief that Brit would be found alive
杜布罗夫尼克官员不愿解释为什么这种密集的搜寻没有更早进行，当地记者暗示警方最终屈服于来自澳大利亚媒体和澳大利亚公民的压力。批评人士认为，杜布罗夫尼克执法部门展现出的巨大努力完全是在作秀，他们并没有真正升级对布里·拉普索恩失踪案的调查。杜布罗夫尼克警方极力为他们现在确保已开展的全方位搜寻布里·拉普索恩失踪案的工作进行辩护，坚称他们正在竭尽所能协助搜寻，尽管他们承认该案目前没有线索。杜布罗夫尼克副警察局长伊万·库里卡（Ivan Kukrika）坚信布里会被活着找到。
Certain they were investigating a disappearance not a murder He once again justified the slow pace of the investigation stating This is not a crime movie where you quickly arrive at an answer The police are doing everything they can These sorts of problems cannot be solved in a day or two as people may expect but systematically As their appeal for information cast a wide international net
他们确信自己调查的是失踪案而非谋杀案，他再次为调查进展缓慢辩护，称：“这不是犯罪电影，不可能一下子就得出答案。警方正在尽一切所能。这些问题不可能像人们所期望的那样在一天或两天内解决，而是需要系统地解决。”随着他们发出的寻人呼吁撒下广泛的国际大网，
Dubrovnik police issued a phone number for anyone anywhere to come forward with details that could lead to Brits whereabouts Relieved Dubrovnik police were finally taking their daughter's disappearance seriously The Lapthorn still harboured resentment that the effort hadn't been made sooner Darren Lapthorn quote If Brit is still alive, she might be on her last breath. So everything possible should be sped up It was evident that Dubrovnik law enforcement were way out of their depth deputy police chief Ivan Kukrika didn't even have a computer in his office And was frustrated to discover that most tip-offs were imparted to the media instead of the authorities
杜布罗夫尼克警方公布了一个电话号码，供任何人、在任何地方提供能够指向布里下落的细节。杜布罗夫尼克警方终于开始认真对待他们女儿的失踪，这让拉普索恩一家感到一丝宽慰，但他们仍然对这种努力没有更早做出感到怨恨。达伦·拉普索恩引述道：“如果布里还活着，她可能只剩最后一口气了。所以一切可能的措施都应该加速。”很明显，杜布罗夫尼克的执法部门已经完全超出了他们的能力范围，副警察局长伊万·库里卡办公室里甚至连一台电脑都没有，而且他沮丧地发现，大多数线索都是透露给媒体而不是当局。
Even the locals didn't seem to be taking the police work seriously trudging through areas cordoned off by crime scene tape With no suspects or useful leads Deputy police chief Kukrika narrowed his focus on the group of international backpackers Brit had ventured to club Fuego with on the night she vanished He was curious to find out why the group had seemingly left the club without their friend And also found it suspicious that many of them had departed Dubrovnik within days of Brits disappearance The deputy requested help in locating the seven backpackers from global police organization Interpol
甚至连当地人似乎也没有把警方的的工作当回事，大摇大摆地穿过被犯罪现场警戒线隔离的区域。由于没有嫌疑人或有用的线索，副警察局长库里卡将重点缩小到布里失踪当晚与之结伴前往Fuego俱乐部的国际背包客群体。他很好奇为什么这群人似乎在没有他们朋友的情况下离开了俱乐部，并且还觉得奇怪的是，他们中的许多人在布里失踪后几天内就离开了杜布罗夫尼克。副局长请求全球警察组织国际刑警组织（Interpol）协助定位这七名背包客。
But the failures of Dubrovnik police were highlighted once more when it was revealed that many of the backpackers had already provided their accounts of the night via the press or social media Frustrated by the lack of contact from authorities The individuals took it upon themselves to publicly share any relevant information they had in the hopes it would lead to Brit Reports from Brits fellow clubgoers were hindered by patchy recollections As many admitted to consuming large amounts of alcohol throughout the night in question The group spent most of the night scattered separately throughout the venue Bumping into one another every so often
但杜布罗夫尼克的警方再次暴露出他们的无能，因为据透露，许多背包客已经通过媒体或社交媒体提供了他们对当晚情况的陈述。由于对当局迟迟不与他们联系感到沮丧，这些人决定主动公开分享他们掌握的任何相关信息，希望能借此找到布里。布里的俱乐部同行们所作的报告由于记忆模糊而受到阻碍，因为许多人承认在涉事当晚饮用了大量酒精。这群人整个晚上大部分时间都分散在场地的不同地方，偶尔才会碰面，
And it was through these interactions that a fairly uniform series of events was collated The group shared a collective sentiment that Britlapthorn was in good spirits during her time at club Fuego On the ground floor of the nightclub, British backpacker Gareth Hopkins looked across the room and witnessed Britlapthorn chatting happily with a group of people he didn't recognize Portuguese backpacker Marina Moreira also saw Brit talking to a group of strangers who she described as mostly tall men At one point during the night, Marina saw Brit enter what looked like a staff only door near the club's main bar area Only to re-emerge a few minutes later Polish-American backpacker Dominik Dabrowiecki who had accompanied Brit on the journey from Mostar to Dubrovnik
正是通过这些互动，整理出了一系列相当统一的事件。这群人有着共同的看法，即布里·拉普索恩在Fuego俱乐部逗留期间心情很好。在夜总会的一楼，英国背包客加雷斯·霍普金斯（Gareth Hopkins）看向房间对面，亲眼看到布里正与一群他不认识的人愉快地交谈。葡萄牙背包客玛丽娜·莫雷拉（Marina Moreira）也看到布里在和一群陌生人聊天，她形容这群人大多是高个子男人。在当晚的某个时候，玛丽娜看到布里走进了俱乐部主要吧台附近一扇看起来像是员工专用的门，几分钟后又重新出来。曾陪同布里从莫斯塔尔（Mostar）前往杜布罗夫尼克的波兰裔美国背包客多米尼克·达布罗维茨基（Dominik Dabrowiecki）
Crossed paths with Brit several times throughout the night Usually on the dance floor where the two acknowledged each other with a quick hello Dominik said I could tell she was drunk, but she looked happy I did not see her dancing with anyone in particular and when I saw her talking to people it was with people from our hostel At approximately 2 a.m Several witnesses saw Brit drop a glass on the dance floor causing it to shatter Club Fuego employees confronted Brit over the breakage and requested that she leave the premises
整个晚上与布里多次擦肩而过，通常是在舞池里，两人以简单的问候互相致意。多米尼克说：“我看得出她喝醉了，但她看起来很高兴。我没有看到她和特定的人跳舞，当我看到她和别人聊天时，都是和我们旅舍的人。”大约凌晨2点，几名目击者看到布里在舞池里摔碎了一个玻璃杯。Fuego俱乐部的员工就打破杯子一事质问布里，并要求她离开场所。
Brit did leave but some 10 minutes later She was seen inside the nightclub again either having been let back or snuck back in At this point she ran into Gareth Hopkins and asked him quote Where are the Croatians followed by something else he couldn't hear over the loud music in the club Gareth wasn't sure who Brit was talking about but noticed she was slurring her words The Dubrovnik backpackers club crew slowly filtered out of club Fuego in dribs and drapes and made their way back to the hostel Some reported asking Brit if she wanted to share a cab, but she wasn't ready to leave yet. So they departed without her The following morning the hazy revelers arose with foggy recollections of the night
布里确实离开了，但大约10分钟后，她被看到再次进入夜总会，要么是被放回来的，要么是偷偷溜进来的。此时，她遇到了加雷斯·霍普金斯，并问他：“克罗地亚人在哪里？”后面还跟着一些由于俱乐部音乐太大声而听不清的话。加雷斯不确定布里在说谁，但注意到她说话口齿不清。杜布罗夫尼克背包客俱乐部的伙伴们三三两两地慢慢离开Fuego俱乐部，踏上了返回旅舍的路。据报道，有些人问布里是否想拼车，但她还没准备好离开，所以他们没有她就先走了。第二天清晨，宿醉狂欢者醒来时，对前晚的记忆十分模糊。
When the realisation dawned that Brit hadn't returned to the hostel They quickly pieced together what memories they retained to try and work out where she may have wound up It was soon determined that the last anyone saw of Britlapthorn was in club Fuego at approximately 3 30 a.m on the morning of Thursday, September 18, 2008 With some reports stating there were three unknown males crowded around her at the time Although it wasn't immediately noticed during initial searches of Britlapthorn's belongings Brit's mobile phone was later found in her dorm room at the Dubrovnik backpackers club Indicating she had left it behind the night she went out
当他们意识到布里没有返回旅舍时，他们迅速拼凑起残存的记忆，试图弄清楚她可能去了哪里。不久后确定，最后一次看到布里·拉普索恩是在2008年9月18日星期四凌晨大约3点30分的Fuego俱乐部，一些报道称当时有三个陌生男子围在她身边。尽管在最初搜查布里·拉普索恩的个人物品时没有立即被发现，但布里的手机后来在杜布罗夫尼克背包客俱乐部的宿舍房间里被找到，这表明她是出门那天晚上把它留在那里的。
An inspection of her phone records revealed a call had been made at 2 57 a.m On September 18, just half an hour before she was last sighted at club Fuego The call was placed to a mobile phone belonging to a Vitsa Perkovich The 33 year old living manager of the Dubrovnik backpackers club who operated the hostel with his parents This phone call immediately cast suspicions on a Vitsa Perkovich Who had left the country in the days after Brit disappeared on what he insisted was a work related trip Whilst abroad Dubrovnik police contacted Perkovich and requested he return to the city so they could speak to him in relation to Britlapthorn Perkovich claimed he barely knew Brit having only met her briefly in the hostel's recreation room at around 10 30 p.m on September 17
对她手机通话记录的检查显示，9月18日凌晨2点57分曾有过一通电话打出，就在她最后一次在Fuego俱乐部被看到的半小时前。这通电话打给了一部属于维特萨·佩科维奇（Vitsa Perkovich）的手机。这位33岁的杜布罗夫尼克背包客俱乐部经理与他的父母一起经营着这家旅舍。这通电话立刻将怀疑的目光投向了维特萨·佩科维奇，他在布里失踪几天后便离开了该国，并坚称这是一次与工作相关的旅行。在国外期间，杜布罗夫尼克警方联系了佩科维奇，要求他返回该市，以便就布里·拉普索恩一案与他谈话。佩科维奇声称他几乎不认识布里，9月17日晚上10点30分左右仅在旅舍的活动室里短暂见过她一面。
The two had a brief conversation about Australia as Perkovich hoped to travel there one day After this interaction Perkovich retired to bed and later arose to complain to his mother that the reality group of backpackers were making too much noise and keeping him awake As Perkovich lacked the confidence to confront them his mother spoke to the guests and asked them to quiet down This prompted several of the guests including Britlapthorn to make the trip to club Fuego Several hours later the 2 57 a.m. Call came through from Brit's mobile phone Perkovich claimed he was asleep at the time and his mobile phone was on silent so he was unaware of the call and it went unanswered Although he could often know explanation as to why Brit was trying to contact him He explained that his mobile phone number was used as the main business line for the Dubrovnik backpackers club
两人简短地聊了聊澳大利亚，因为佩科维奇希望有一天能去那里旅行。这次互动后，佩科维奇上床睡觉，随后醒来向母亲抱怨说，这群背包客背包客闹出太大动静，吵得他无法入睡。由于佩科维奇缺乏直面他们的勇气，他的母亲便去找客人们谈话，请他们保持安静。这促使包括布里·拉普索恩在内的几位客人前往Fuego俱乐部。几个小时后，来自布里手机的凌晨2点57分的电话打了进来。佩科维奇声称他当时在睡觉，手机开着静音，所以不知道有这通电话，因而未接听。尽管他无法解释为什么布里试图联系他，但他解释说，他的手机号码被用作杜布罗夫尼克背包客俱乐部的业务热线。
A number all guests were given upon checking in and told to ring should they need help with bookings inquiries or emergencies Adding another layer to the mystery was the lack of explanation as to how exactly Brit's mobile phone wound up at the hostel The lap thorns believed with utmost certainty that Brit would not go out without her mobile phone If she had accidentally left the device at the hostel before she left the club Fuego It begged the question as to who made the 2 57 a.m. Call to a vitsa Perkovich and why? If Brit did have her phone with her at the nightclub There was no explanation as to why it was used to make a call to a vitsa Perkovich half an hour before she was last seen Nor how the phone ended up back in her dorm
所有客人在办理入住时都会拿到这个号码，并被告知如果需要预订、咨询或紧急情况方面的帮助，可以拨打该号码。给这个谜团增添另一层色彩的是，对于布里的手机究竟是如何回到旅舍的，一直缺乏解释。拉普索恩一家极其确定，布里出门绝不会不带手机。如果她在离开Fuego俱乐部之前不小心将设备落在了旅舍，这就引出了一个问题：是谁在凌晨2点57分给维特萨·佩科维奇打了电话？为什么打？如果布里在夜总会时确实随身带着手机，那么在最后一次被看到前半小时，为什么它被用来给维特萨·佩科维奇打电话，又是怎么回到她的宿舍里的？
Deputy police chief Ivan Kukrika confirmed that the phone call made from Brit's mobile on the evening of her disappearance was of great interest But insisted the key to the mystery lay with the backpacker. She was with the club Fuego As such after 36 hours of questioning Evitsa Perkovich was released from custody with police officially ruling He was no longer being viewed as a suspect in the case Upon his release Evitsa Perkovich told a Croatian newspaper that none of the other guests who had attended club Fuego with Brit lap thorn Were at all worried when she didn't return from the club
副警察局长伊万·库里卡证实，在布里失踪当晚从她的手机打出的那通电话非常重要，但他坚持认为解开谜团的关键在于她在Fuego俱乐部时与之在一起的背包客。因此，在经过36小时的审讯后，维特萨·佩科维奇被释放，警方正式裁定他不再被视为此案的嫌疑人。获释后，维特萨·佩科维奇向一家克罗地亚报纸透露，当布里·拉普索恩没有从俱乐部返回时，其他和她一起去Fuego俱乐部的客人们一点也不担心。
quote They thought she was that kind of person He claimed to have spoken to staff at other hostels Brit had stayed in during her travels And he said they described the 21 year old as a very kind polite person, but with a reckless side Upon learning of Evitsa's comments Elka lap thorn was heartbroken and warned Evitsa to be careful quote Every mother knows their little girl. I know my little girl and she's not that kind of girl I think he's being very clever in trying to put the blame on Brit
引用他的话说：“他们以为她就是那种人。”他声称自己曾与布里在旅行期间住过的其他旅舍的员工交谈过，并表示他们将这位21岁的女孩描述为一个非常善良、礼貌，但也有鲁莽一面的人。得知维特萨的这番言论后，埃尔卡·拉普索恩心碎不已，并警告维特萨小心点，她引用道：“每个母亲都了解自己的女儿。我了解我的女儿，她才不是那种女孩。我觉得他很聪明，想把责任推给布里。”
Tara Reynolds who had traveled with Brit in Poland said I'm very angry and upset for Perkovich to say such things In one breath. He says he doesn't know her and in another makes these assumptions about her It makes me suspicious very suspicious Evitsa was not the only member of the Perkovich family that exhibited suspicious behavior during the Brit lap thorn investigation As the search for Brit continued the lap thorns received an anonymous phone call in their Dubrovnik hotel from a local Who claimed to have seen Evitsa Perkovich's mother Milka at the post office on the day of Brit's disappearance
曾在波兰与布里一起旅行的塔拉·雷诺兹说：“佩科维奇说出这样的话，让我感到非常愤怒和难过。他一面说自己不认识她，另一面又对她做出这样的假设。这让我感到怀疑，非常怀疑。”在调查布里·拉普索恩失踪案期间，维特萨并不是佩科维奇家族中唯一表现出可疑行为的成员。随着对布里的搜寻持续进行，拉普索恩一家在杜布罗夫尼克的酒店里接到了一通匿名电话，打来电话的是当地人，自称在布里失踪当天看到维特萨·佩科维奇的母亲米尔卡（Milka）在邮局。
Milka Perkovich was attempting to mail a passport to Australia But left after being advised passports could not be sent through the post The caller alleged the passport belonged to Brit lap thorn This information although seemingly compelling could not be verified and the lap thorns never heard from the caller again The official investigation conducted by Dubrovnik law enforcement into Brit lap thorns disappearance lasted just 10 days And resulted in a brief two page report detailing their limited findings One new piece of information came from a Croatian witness who claimed to have seen Brit lap thorn laughing and dancing with an English speaking man at Club Fuego throughout the night of her disappearance It was unclear if this was someone unknown to Brit or one of her companions from the Dubrovnik Backpackers Club Hostel
米尔卡·佩科维奇当时试图将一本护照寄往澳大利亚，但在被告知护照不能通过邮寄方式发送后便离开了。来电者声称这本护照属于布里·拉普索恩。这条信息虽然看似引人注目，却无法得到证实，拉普索恩一家也再没有接到过该来电者的电话。杜布罗夫尼克执法部门对布里·拉普索恩失踪案进行的官方调查仅持续了10天，并出具了一份简短的两页报告，详述了他们有限的调查结果。一项新信息来自一名克罗地亚证人，他声称在布里失踪当晚，看到布里在Fuego俱乐部和一个说英语的男人有说有笑、一同跳舞。目前尚不清楚这个人是布里不认识的陌生人，还是她在杜布罗夫尼克背包客俱乐部旅舍的同伴之一。
It was the chief of the Dubrovnik police force Ivan Kresik who fronted the media at a press conference after the release of the report Although the report provided no answers as to what could have happened to Brit lap thorn Kresik was confident that the Dubrovnik police would still locate the young Australian alive Quote We are not searching for a body. We are searching for a girl It is now a matter of time until we find an answer to the mystery But I am sure that we will answer all the questions as to what happened and I will do everything as a human being and as a policeman I still hope she is alive That is a hope
报告发布后，杜布罗夫尼克警察局长伊万·克雷西克（Ivan Kresik）在新闻发布会上出面面对媒体。尽管该报告没有提供关于布里·拉普索恩可能遭遇了什么的答案，但克雷西克坚信杜布罗夫尼克警方仍会找到这位年轻的澳大利亚女性并确保她活着。引用他的话说：“我们不是在寻找一具尸体，我们是在寻找一个女孩。找到这个谜团答案只是时间问题。但我确信我们会解答关于所发生一切的所有问题，作为一个凡人和一名警察，我会尽我所能。我仍然希望她活着。这是一个希望，”
a real one Monday October 6 2008 marked 72 hours since Dale Lap Thorn arrived to the city of Dubrovnik It had been a hellish 18 days for the father a physically and emotionally exhausting experience Hended by deficient police work and complex diplomacy Despite all the obstacles thrown his way Dale was fuelled by unwavering determination to bring his daughter home Just a few hundred meters east from the entrance of Club Fuego is Dubrovnik's west harbour Situated in a spectacular stretch of shoreline known as Bononovo Bay The scenic bay is sheltered by a soaring 40 meter cliff face which frames the crystal clear waters of the Adriatic Sea
一个真正的希望。2008年10月6日星期一，标志着戴尔·拉普索恩抵达杜布罗夫尼克市已经过去了72小时。对这位父亲来说，这是炼狱般的18天，一段在身体和情感上都极度疲惫的经历，伴随着糟糕的警察工作和复杂的外交。尽管遇到了重重阻碍，戴尔内心坚定的决心依然支撑着他，要将女儿带回家。距离Fuego俱乐部入口向东仅几百米，便是杜布罗夫尼克的西港（west harbour）。这个风景如画的海湾坐落在一片壮丽的海岸线上，被称为博诺沃湾（Bononovo Bay），四周环绕着高耸40米的悬崖峭壁，衬托出亚得里亚海晶莹剔透的海水。
The beach below is accessible via a steep set of stairs with metal ladders affixed to concrete platforms That allow swimmers to exit the water after launching off from one of the many dive spots The area is surrounded by holiday homes and five-star resorts popular with tourists and locals alike Who gather to sunbathe play cards or cook barbecues while admiring the picturesque coastal views The serene deep waters of the bay host a variety of marine life making it an ideal location for boating and fishing As 11 o'clock approached on the morning of October 6 Local fishermen boating off a cove near Bononovo Bay caught sight of something floating on the surface of the sea Upon realising what they had come across they immediately contacted Dubrovnik law enforcement
下方的海滩可以通过一组陡峭的台阶到达，台阶上固定着连着混凝土平台的金属梯子，供游泳者从众多跳水点之一跃入水中后上岸。该地区周围环绕着度假屋和五星级度假村，深受游客和当地人的喜爱，他们聚集在这里晒日光浴、打牌或烧烤，同时欣赏风景如画的海岸风光。海湾宁静深邃的海水孕育了丰富的海洋生物，使其成为划船和钓鱼的理想场所。随着10月6日上午11点临近，在博诺沃湾附近一个小海湾划船的当地渔民发现海面上有什么东西在漂浮。一旦意识到他们发现了什么，他们立即联系了杜布罗夫尼克执法部门。
Water police arrived to the location where they found the partial remains of a human body in an advanced state of decomposition The remains were so severely damaged Authorities were unable to determine whether they were those of a male or a female Making an immediate identification impossible Dubrovnik police withheld news of the discovery from the public But it didn't take long for word of the body found near Bononovo Bay to lead to the press Dale and Darren Lappthorn were still deep in their search for Brit when the news of the body ran out of control They were immediately struck with overwhelming emotion assuming the body had to be hers
水警赶到现场，在那里发现了处于高度腐烂状态的人类部分遗骸。由于遗骸损毁严重，当局无法确定死者是男性还是女性，这使得立即辨认身份成为不可能。杜布罗夫尼克警方对公众隐瞒了这一发现的消息，但博诺沃湾附近发现尸体一事很快便传到了媒体耳中。当尸体消息失控传开时，戴尔·拉普索恩和达伦·拉普索恩仍在全力寻找布里。他们立刻受到强烈的感情冲击，假设这具尸体一定属于她。
To make the situation even more traumatising for the family They heard about the grim breakthrough via the media instead of being personally informed by officials Although the body had yet to be identified Dale Lappthorn made the difficult call to his wife in Australia Informing her their daughter may have finally been found Elka Lappthorn quote I don't know whether it was relief I sort of felt a calmness there because I said to Dale and Darren. I'm sure it's Brit We just have to be prepared for that
为了让这个家庭的处境更加痛苦，他们是通过媒体得知这个严峻的突破，而不是由官员亲自通知他们的。尽管尸体尚未得到身份确认，但戴尔·拉普索恩还是艰难地给远在澳大利亚的妻子打了电话，通知她女儿可能终于被找到了。埃尔卡·拉普索恩说：“我不知道这算不算是一种解脱，我内心涌起一种平静感，因为我对戴尔和达伦说：‘我相信那是布里。我们只能对此做好心理准备。’ ”
However, Dubrovnik police were quick to deny the body was that of the Australian backpacker As Brit had only been missing for 18 days and the state of the human remains found on Bononovo Bay Indicated the body had been in the water for months Deputy police chief Ivan Kulkrika held a press conference where he stated We can almost for sure tell that the body is not Brit's body He explained the remains were more likely those of an illegal immigrant from Albania or Montenegro Who had been dumped or fallen over the side of a boat some time ago Kulkrika's statements reignited hopes Brit Lappthorn could still be found alive
然而，杜布罗夫尼克警方迅速否认这具尸体是那名澳大利亚背包客的。由于布里特失踪仅仅18天，而博诺沃湾发现的人类遗骸状态表明，尸体在水中已经泡了几个月。副警察局长伊万·库尔克里卡举行了新闻发布会，他表示：“我们几乎可以肯定是，这具尸体不是布里特的。”他解释说，遗体更有可能属于一名来自阿尔巴尼亚或黑山的非法移民，此人不久前从船上掉落或被抛入海中。库尔克里卡的一番话重新燃起了人们找到活着的布里特·拉普索恩的希望。
Back home her mother told the press Every day it's getting worse and worse and I wonder what else we are going to hear Why hasn't Brit been found for heaven's sake? For Dale Lappthorn the discovery of the body almost brought an end to the painful mystery of what happened to his daughter Quote it is just extraordinary it is your worst nightmare in many ways With this body we almost had some closure, you know some closure I can at least say I'm going home with Brit
远在澳大利亚的家乡，她的母亲对记者说：“情况每天都在变得越来越糟糕，我不知道我们还会听到什么消息。看在上帝的份上，为什么还没找到布里特？”对于戴尔·拉普索恩来说，这具尸体的发现几乎为他女儿身上发生的痛苦谜团画上了句号。引用他的话：“这太不寻常了，在许多方面这就是你的终极噩梦。有了这具尸体，我们差不多算是有了一个了结，你知道的，算是有了一个了结。我至少可以说，我要带着布里特回家了。”
But now we are back to square one As the search for Brit Lappthorn continued her father wrote a letter to the public titled Please help me find my Brit which was published by Australian newspaper The Daily Telegraph In a Dale Rowe My daughter Brit Lappthorn is missing There are no highs for our family right now it's just lows to extreme lows I feel shattered, I feel exhausted, I feel broken And I wonder if I will be able to go on the next day
但现在我们又回到了原点。随着对布里特·拉普索恩的搜寻仍在继续，她的父亲写了一封致公众的信，题为《请帮我找到我的布里特》，这封信被澳大利亚报纸《每日电讯报》刊登。戴尔在文中写道：“我的女儿布里特·拉普索恩失踪了。我们家现在没有任何高兴的时刻，只有低谷到极度的低谷。我感到心碎，我感到筋疲力尽，我感到崩溃。我不知道自己是否还能撑到第二天。”
In this situation I just have to keep on driving Our family have got to do everything we can to find Brit My son Darren and I ask how can we go home without her? The answer is we cannot We are still discovering bit by bit what happened the night she disappeared There are so many conflicting reports that make it difficult to get a true picture Yet this case should be so simple Hostel, nightclub, the distance between, a populated place, lots of traffic
在这种情况下，我只能继续前行。我们全家必须尽一切努力找到布里特。我和我的儿子达伦都在问，我们怎么能没有她就回家呢？答案是我们不能。我们仍在一点一点地拼凑她失踪当晚发生的事情。有这么多相互矛盾的报道，让人很难了解真相。然而，这个案子本来应该很简单：旅馆、夜总会、之间的距离、人口稠密的地方、来往的车辆。
It begs the question why is this so difficult to solve? She hasn't just vanished off the face of the earth that's just not Brit She hasn't done a runner there was no reason to She loved life, she loved being home, she loved her friends Brit's story has touched the hearts of many people Anyone who loves their family can relate to it They relate to the fear of losing a loved one A child
这不禁让人产生疑问：为什么这个案子这么难破？她不可能就这样凭空消失，那根本不是布里特。她没有私奔，也没有任何理由这么做。她热爱生活，热爱家乡，热爱她的朋友。布里特的故事触动了许多人的心。任何爱自己家人的人都能对此感同身受。他们感同身受的是失去所爱之人的恐惧，失去一个孩子。
I am very thankful for the huge level of public support I have only one goal and that's to find my daughter I will use every tool possible to do that I will not say I should have Nor will I say I could have Despite the confidence of Dubrovnik police that the body found floating in the waters near Bononovo Bay was not Brit Lapthorn Her family provided them with blood tests, dental records and DNA samples
我非常感谢公众给予的大力支持。我只有一个目标，那就是找到我的女儿。我会用尽一切可能的手段去实现这个目标。我不会说“我本应该”，我也不会说“我本可以”。尽管杜布罗夫尼克警方坚信在博诺沃湾附近水域漂浮的尸体不是布里特·拉普索恩，但她的家人还是向他们提供了血液样本、牙科记录和DNA样本，
in order to rule out the possibility that it could be their daughter Four days later, an analysis conducted by Croatian forensics determined the Lapthorn's worst fears to be true It had been 22 days since their daughter mysteriously vanished from Plub Fuego in the early hours of September 18 But finally, Brit Lapthorn had been found After taking time to address his overwhelming grief They all lapthorn fronted the media
以排除这具尸体可能是他们女儿的可能性。四天后，克罗地亚法医进行的分析证实了拉普索恩一家的最坏担忧：这是真的。距离他们的女儿在9月18日凌晨从普拉布·菲戈神秘失踪已经过去了22天。但最终，人们还是找到了布里特·拉普索恩。在花时间平复了排山倒海般的悲痛之后，戴尔·拉普索恩面对了媒体。
Quote I came to Dubrovnik to bring Brit home We did not achieve our main objective, which was to bring her home alive But we have the consolation that we are taking her home We go home with Brit on her last journey with us That is better than no closure at all It's a very shallow closure and one we will never get over And one we will never get over
他说：“我来杜布罗夫尼克是为了接布里特回家。我们没有实现我们的主要目标，也就是活着把她接回家。但我们得到的安慰是，我们正在接她回家。我们要和布里特一起踏上她与我们同行的最后一段旅程。这总比什么都不知道、没有一个了结要好。这是一个非常肤浅的了结，也是一个我们永远无法释怀的了结。而且是我们永远无法释怀的了结。”
But we have something We have failed But we have not totally failed Forensic experts deemed it lucky that Brit's body had been discovered at all given there was very little tissue remaining to keep it afloat Only approximately 40% of Brit's remains were recovered with several organs and limbs missing as well as most of her teeth and hair Deputy Chief of Police Ivan Kulkrika fronted the press, stating
但我们得到了某些东西。我们失败了，但我们并没有彻底失败。法医专家认为，布里特遗体能被找到简直是走运，因为当时仅存一点点维持尸体漂浮的组织。布里特只有大约40%的遗骸被找回，几个内脏器官和四肢缺失，大部分牙齿和头发也不翼而飞。副警察局长伊万·库尔克里卡出面面对媒体，表示：
I have to admit that I had, based on the state the body was in, really thought that it was not Brit This left Croatian authorities to believe the Australian must have been in the water for the duration of her disappearance an assumption which only raised more perplexing questions for the lapthorns Even if Brit had been floating in the water for the whole 18 days she was missing the timing didn't correspond with the severe extent of decay and destruction sustained to her body The fact that no one saw Brit's body during that time was even more baffling to her family
“我不得不承认，根据尸体当时的状态，我真的以为那不是布里特。”这使得克罗地亚当局认为，这位澳大利亚人在她失踪的整个期间一定一直泡在水里。这种假设只给拉普索恩一家带来了更多令人费解的问题。即便布里特在她失踪的整整18天里一直漂在水里，这个时间也与她尸体遭受严重腐烂和破坏的程度不符。没有人在这期间看到过布里特的尸体，这让她的家人感到更加困惑，
given that Bononobo Bay was a high traffic area popular with swimmers and boaters and overlooked by an observation area visited by hundreds of tourists daily These considerations further substantiated Dale lapthorn's suspicions that foul play was involved in Brit's death Quote Brit did not jump off a cliff, cut her legs off on the way down and do something else to decompose herself As an explanation for the rapid decomposition of Brit's body
因为博诺沃湾是一个交通繁忙的地区，深受游泳者和划船者的喜爱，并且俯瞰着一个每天都有数百名游客参观的观景台。这些考量进一步证实了戴尔·拉普索恩的怀疑，即布里特之死涉及谋杀。他说：“布里特没有跳崖，没有在下落途中切断双腿，也没有做其他什么事来让自己分解。”为了解释布里特尸体迅速腐烂的原因，
Dale developed the theory that Brit may have been killed and dumped at sea to perpetrate as weighing her body down by storing rocks in her clothing Her remains may have only recently arisen to the surface after the rocks became dislodged Dale's theory wasn't without precedent an incident three years earlier in 2005 bore striking similarities to the Brit Lapthorn case when a badly decomposed body was found floating in the waters of Croatia's Istrian peninsula Local police were adamant the body had been in the water for at least eight months
戴尔提出了这样一种理论：布里特可能被杀害并抛尸大海，凶手通过在她的衣服里塞入石头来增加尸体重量，企图掩人耳目。直到石头脱落后，她的遗骸才可能最近浮出水面。戴尔的这一理论并非没有先例。三年前的2005年发生过一起事件，与布里特·拉普索恩案惊人地相似：当时在克罗地亚伊斯特拉半岛的海域发现了一具高度腐烂的漂浮尸体。当地警方坚称这具尸体在水中至少已经泡了八个月，
ruling out the possibility it was 30-year-old British tourist Peter Rushton who had gone missing from a nightclub in the Croatian town of Poric five weeks earlier However, the remains were later identified to be those of Peter Rushton Decomposition was accelerated due to the fact his badly beaten body had been put in a sack filled with fishing weights before being thrown overboard Two Croatian men were later charged with his murder Upon the discovery of Brit Lapthorn's body rumors ran rife over the circumstances leading to her death Some believed Brit had stumbled through the dark towards the West Harbour
从而排除了死者是30岁英国游客彼得·鲁什顿的可能性，彼得·鲁什顿在五周前从克罗地亚波里奇镇的一家夜总会失踪。然而，这具遗体后来被确认就是彼得·鲁什顿。由于他惨遭殴打的尸体在被扔进海里之前被装进了一个装满渔业铅块的麻袋里，因此尸体腐烂加速了。两名克罗地亚男子后来被指控谋杀了他。在发现布里特·拉普索恩的尸体后，关于导致她死亡的各种情况的谣言满天飞。有人认为布里特在黑暗中跌跌撞撞地走向西港，
and accidentally fallen from the coastal cliffs Others suspected she may have participated in a late night swim before accidentally drowning in the surf Others shared the sentiments of the Lapthorn family and were convinced the backpacker had met with foul play To determine Brit's cause of death experts aimed to clarify key factors including the location where she had entered the sea But this was soon deemed impossible as the area of water where Brit's body was found was characterised by strong winds and powerful currents
然后不小心从海岸悬崖上掉了下去。其他人怀疑她可能参与了一场深夜游泳，然后不小心在海浪中溺水身亡。其他人则分享了拉普索恩一家的看法，坚信这名背包客遭遇了谋杀。为了确定布里特的死因，专家们旨在厘清关键因素，包括她入海的地点。但不久之后，这被认为是不可能的，因为发现布里特尸体的海域具有大风和强洋流的特征，
meaning the exact entry point could not be identified To establish whether Brit fell from a height or entered the water at sea level experts studied her skeletal remains However, as the coastline framing Bononovo Bay featured steep jagged cliffs, deep seashells and rocky outcrops the cause of bone fractures could be from a multitude of possible sources Breakages would appear the same regardless of whether Brit fell from a cliff was thrown in or the current dragged her body into the cliff face The rapid decomposition of Brit's remains only added more complexities
这意味着无法确定具体的入海点。为了确定布里特是从高处坠落还是在海平面入海，专家们研究了她的骨骼遗骸。然而，由于环绕博诺沃湾的海岸线有着陡峭的锯齿状悬崖、深深的海贝和岩石露头，骨折的原因可能来自多种潜在的源头。无论布里特是从悬崖上掉下来、被扔下去，还是被洋流拖向悬崖峭壁，骨折的断裂情况看起来都是一样的。布里特遗体的迅速腐烂，只会给尚未查明的死因增添更多复杂性。
to the yet to be determined cause of death The Brovnik police told Dale Lapthorn the reason his daughter's body was so badly decomposed was because, quote, the water was warm But the temperature of Bononovo Bay's water in late September and early October could vary anywhere between 16 and 22 degrees Celsius significantly colder than the ocean's mid-year temperatures which peaked at 28 degrees Prolonged water base to decomposition can cause hair and skin to come away from the body but experts were at a loss to explain how most of Brit's teeth were missing
杜布罗夫尼克警方告诉戴尔·拉普索恩，他女儿的尸体之所以腐烂得如此严重，是因为“水很温暖”。但9月下旬和10月上旬博诺沃湾的水温在16到22摄氏度之间波动，明显比年中达到28摄氏度峰值的海水温度要冷。长时间浸泡在水中会导致头发和皮肤脱落，但专家们无法解释为什么布里特的大多数牙齿都不见了，
including the more resilient molars Although not an impossible result of decomposition, the loss of her molar teeth was highly unusual The possibility that marine life played a part also seemed unlikely Croatian waters are home to a variety of marine life but very few would be capable of removing human limbs Sharks had been known to swim through the Adriatic Sea but their presence was extremely rare A cursory search of the Bononovo Bay area only uncovered one of Brit's personal belongings
包括那些更有韧性的臼齿。虽然这不是腐烂绝不可能产生的结果，但臼齿的缺失极其罕见。海洋生物起了作用的可能性似乎也不大。克罗地亚水域栖息着各种海洋生物，但极少有生物能够扯掉人类四肢。人们知道亚得里亚海有鲨鱼游过，但它们的出现极其罕见。对博诺沃湾地区的粗略搜寻只找到了布里特的一件私人物品：
The shirt she had been wearing on the night of her disappearance which was found floating in the sea a short distance away from her body The other items Brit had on her including her wallet, cannon power shot G9 camera and the remainder of her clothing including her leggings and shoes were not found The possibility that Brit drowned couldn't be ruled out but it couldn't be confirmed either as her lungs were never recovered It was a topic of debate as Brit's body was found unclothed which is unusual for drowning victims Rumors she could have gone skinny-dipping were refuted by those closest to Brit
她在失踪当晚穿的那件衬衫，被发现漂浮在离她尸体不远的海面上。布里特随身携带的其他物品，包括她的钱包、佳能PowerShot G9相机以及其余的衣服（包括紧身裤和鞋子），都没有找到。布里特溺水的可能性无法排除，但也无法证实，因为她的肺部从未被找回。这是一个争论的话题，因为布里特的尸体被发现时赤身裸体，这对于溺水受害者来说很不寻常。那些与布里特最亲近的人反驳了她可能去裸泳的传言，
who described her as conservative and given the remainder of her clothing was not located at the water's edge it seemed unlikely Yet some suggested her clothing may have been blown away by the strong Bora winds The cliffs above Bononovo Bay were a local suicide spot but Brit had no history of suicidal thoughts or self-harming tendencies On the contrary she was consistently described as happy and secure with many positive elements in her life
他们形容她性格保守，而且既然其余的衣服没有在水边找到，这种可能性似乎不大。然而，有人暗示她的衣服可能被强烈的布拉风吹走了。博诺沃湾上方的悬崖是当地人自杀的热门地点，但布里特没有任何自杀倾向或自残倾向的历史。相反，她一直被形容为快乐和安全感十足，生活中有很多积极的因素，
including her travels, studies, friends, family and a boyfriend One of the last postcards Brit sent to her parents in Australia noted she wasn't ready to go home yet as she was having so much fun Longing for answers the Lapthorn family anxiously awaited the results of an autopsy certain it would put an end to the speculation and reveal the indisputable truth of what happened to Brit It took a week for Dubrovnik forensic officials to complete the post-mortem examination of Brit Lapthorn's body
包括她的旅行、学业、朋友、家人和一个男朋友。布里特寄给澳大利亚父母的最后几张明信片之一提到，她玩得太开心了，还不想回家。为了寻找答案，拉普索恩一家焦急地等待着尸检结果，确信这会平息猜测，并揭示布里特身上到底发生了什么无可争辩的真相。杜布罗夫尼克法医官员花了一周时间完成了对布里特·拉普索恩尸体的验尸工作。
The accompanying report immediately drew outrage from the Lapthorn family, the Australian media and members of the public At just two pages long the autopsy report was noticeably underwritten and contained an obvious lack of insight It described the damage sustained to Brit's body but made no attempt to explain how such damage had occurred The report blamed the lack of detailed information on the poor state the body was in but provided no explanation as to why the remains had deteriorated so rapidly
随附的报告立即引起了拉普索恩一家、澳大利亚媒体和公众的愤怒。这份尸检报告只有两页长，明显写得很草率，而且明显缺乏见解。它描述了布里特尸体受到的损害，但没有试图解释这种损害是如何发生的。报告将缺乏详细信息归咎于尸体状况不佳，但没有解释为什么遗骸会恶化得如此之快。
In one final blow the report indicated that no further comprehensive scientific testing had been undertaken and simply ruled Brit Lapthorn's cause of death as unknown A disappointed Dale Lapthorn slammed the autopsy report as childish stating quote A grade 12 student could do a better job than this Up until this point the Dubrovnik law enforcement's perceived incompetence had been attributed to their lack of experience in dealing with the case of this nature But now their indifference in determining what happened to Brit Lapthorn was being viewed as intentional Australians believed the Dubrovnik police were going to great lengths to sweep the
在最后一次打击中，报告指出没有进行进一步的综合科学检测，并干脆将布里特·拉普索恩的死因定为“未知”。失望的戴尔·拉普索恩抨击这份尸检报告“幼稚”，并称：“一个12年级的学生都能比这做得更好。”在此之前，杜布罗夫尼克执法部门被认为无能，是因为他们缺乏处理此类案件的经验。但现在，他们在查明布里特·拉普索恩身上发生了什么事情上的冷漠，被视为是故意的。澳大利亚人认为，杜布罗夫尼克警方正在竭尽全力将此案
case under the rug to ensure their city's positive reputation would not be damaged by word of a foreign tourist being murdered on their streets After the release of the Croatian autopsy report it was announced that the Brit Lapthorn's body would be re-examined in Australia by a Victorian coroner The Lapthorns found solace in this decision with Dale telling the media quote If it concurs with what has been investigated in Croatia fine and good I accept that I asked the Croatian people not to see this as an insult or anything It's just a family right to be able to have a second opinion and for us to rest peacefully
地毯底下（掩盖真相），以确保他们的城市不会因为外国游客在他们的街道上被谋杀的消息而损害其光辉的声誉。在克罗地亚尸检报告发布后，有消息称，维多利亚州的验尸官将在澳大利亚对布里特·拉普索恩的遗体进行重新检查。拉普索恩一家在这个决定中找到了一点慰藉，戴尔对媒体说：“如果它与克罗地亚调查的情况一致，那就很好，我接受这一点。我请求克罗地亚人民不要把这视为侮辱或其他什么。这只是一个家庭要求有第二次意见的权利，也是为了让我们能够安心地
in that the correct assessment was done Before returning to Australia Dale and Darren Lapthorn boated in Bonobo Bay scouring the rocky bays and inlets near the location Brit's body was found When asked what they were looking for Dale said he didn't want to sound gruesome but they were worried something had been missed like a leg or an arm Despite their efforts no further remains were recovered At dawn on October 17 Dale and Darren Lapthorn together with Brit's boyfriend Simon sailed out into the cool morning mist of Bonobo Bay where they laid a wreath and
确信做了正确的评估。”在返回澳大利亚之前，戴尔和达伦·拉普索恩乘船游览了博诺沃湾，搜寻发现布里特尸体地点附近的岩石海湾和小海湾。当被问及他们在找什么时，戴尔说他不想听起来毛骨悚然，但他们担心有什么遗漏了，比如一条腿或一只胳膊。尽管他们尽了最大努力，但没有找回更多的遗骸。10月17日黎明，戴尔和达伦·拉普索恩以及布里特的男友西蒙一起驶入博诺沃湾凉爽的早晨薄雾中，他们在那里献上花圈，并将
scattered white rose petals upon the water where Brit's body was found Mansard Roof a song by indie rock band Vampire Weekend was played from Brit's iPod The upbeat song bringing the essence of her vibrant spirit to the somber occasion Promising to remember Brit as the vivacious young woman she was Dale Lapthorn stated The pain we cannot bear is all those things that she wanted to do and will never get the chance The following day October 18 marked a month to the day since Brit Lapthorn went missing That night more than 1000 people gathered at Flagstaff Gardens in Brit's home city of Melbourne, Australia to hold a candlelight vigil in her honour and pay their respects to her family
白色玫瑰花瓣撒在发现布里特尸体的水面上。独立摇滚乐队吸血鬼周末（Vampire Weekend）的歌曲《曼萨德屋顶》（Mansard Roof）从布里特的iPod中播放出来。这首欢快的歌曲将她充满活力的精神本质带入了这庄严的场合。戴尔·拉普索恩发誓要记住布里特作为她曾经那个活泼年轻女子的样子，他说道：“我们无法承受的痛苦是她所有想要去做却再也没有机会去做的事情。”第二天，即10月18日，是布里特·拉普索恩失踪一个月的日子。那天晚上，1000多名民众聚集在澳大利亚墨尔本布里特家乡的旗杆花园（Flagstaff Gardens），为她举行烛光晚会，以表达对她的缅怀和对她家人的敬意。
Brit's friends, relatives, classmates and strangers sat on picnic blankets watching in silence as the sun set in the springtime sky As night fell the parklands were illuminated by hundreds of flickering candles Elka Lapthorn told the crowd of mourners quote I think people especially backpackers should get on with their adventures and experiences but just look after each other a bit more I think Brit possibly was in the wrong place at the wrong time with the wrong person and it just should not have happened not to Brit not to anyone else The next day the entire Lapthorn family were reunited after a challenging and painful period apart A formal memorial service titled a ceremony of love for Brit was held in South Moraine
布里特的亲朋好友、同学和陌生人坐在野餐垫上，在春天的天空中夕阳西下时默默注视着。夜幕降临，公园被数百支闪烁的蜡烛照亮。埃尔卡·拉普索恩对哀悼的人群说：“我认为人们，尤其是背包客，应该继续他们的冒险和经历，但要多照顾彼此一点。我认为布里特可能在错误的时间、错误的地点遇到了错误的人，这本不该发生，对布里特如此，对其他人也是如此。”第二天，在经历了一段充满挑战和痛苦的分离之后，拉普索恩全家终于团聚了。一场名为“致布里特的爱之仪式”的正式追悼会在莫兰南部举行，
with over 600 mourners in attendance wearing ribbons of Brit's favourite colour purple The programs were covered with purple stars and featured a picture of Brit her contagious smile and enthusiastic thumbs up perfectly encapsulating her lively personality Stories of Brit's idyllic childhood and adolescence were retold by loved ones including the time at age five she attempted to leave home but only made it as far as halfway down her driveway Another story revealed that Brit's first ever mobile phone bill totaled more than $1,200 much to the horror of her father At age 15 the industrious Brit sought out her first job in a local charcoal chicken takeaway food shop Each tale was told with humour and warmth and
有600多名哀悼者出席，他们佩戴着布里特最喜欢的紫色丝带。节目单上印满了紫色的星星，并附有一张布里特的照片，她那具有感染力的微笑和热情的大拇指手势完美地概括了她活泼的个性。亲人们重新讲述了布里特田园诗般的童年和青春期的故事，包括她五岁时试图离家出走，但只走到了自家车道的一半。另一个故事透露，布里特的第一笔手机账单总额超过了1200美元，这让她的父亲大惊失色。在15岁时，勤劳的布里特在当地一家炭烧鸡外卖店找到了她的第一份工作。每一个故事都充满了幽默和温情，
accompanied by a photo montage reflecting the full and adventurous life Brit created for herself After the ceremony, 21 purple balloons were released, each one symbolising a year of Brit's life They all lapthorn thanked the crowd for their ongoing support during this unspeakable tragedy and implored everyone to appreciate the preciousness of life and value their family A private burial was postponed as Brit's family awaited the results of a second autopsy The second post-mortem of Brit Lapthorn's body was conducted by David Ranson, an associate professor from the Victorian Institute of Forensic Medicine This examination incorporated a series of tests that the initial autopsy had failed to conduct including a toxicological
并伴随着一个照片蒙太奇，反映了布里特为自己创造的充实而充满冒险的人生。仪式结束后，21个紫色气球被放飞，每一个气球都象征着布里特的一年生命。拉普索恩全家感谢人群在这场难以言喻的悲剧发生期间给予的持续支持，并恳求大家珍惜生命的宝贵，重视自己的家人。由于拉普索恩一家在等待第二次尸检的结果，一场私人葬礼被推迟了。对布里特·拉普索恩遗体的第二次验尸由维多利亚法医学研究所的副教授大卫·兰森进行。这次检查包含了一系列最初尸检未能进行的测试，其中包括一项毒理学
analysis that revealed no alcohol or any other common drugs or poisons were present in Brit's system The small amount of body tissue that remained was thoroughly examined and no bruises, abrasions, lacerations or incisions were identified Based on the damage to her skeletal remains it was determined that the trauma sustained to Brit's long bones was consistent with wave and tidal action against rocky surfaces Rib fractures were also present, although it couldn't be determined whether these occurred whilst Brit was alive or post-mortem Damage to other parts of the skeletal structure was attributed to scavenging marine life According to Professor Ranson, the absence of trauma to Brit's skull and upper limbs
分析，结果显示布里特体内没有酒精或任何其他常见药物或毒物。留在身上的少量人体组织受到了彻底检查，没有发现任何瘀伤、擦伤、撕裂伤或切口。根据对她骨骼遗骸的损害情况，经确定，布里特长骨受到的创伤与波浪和潮汐对岩石表面的冲刷作用相一致。肋骨也出现了骨折，尽管无法确定这些骨折发生在她生前还是死后。骨骼结构其他部分的损坏则归因于海洋生物的啃食。根据兰森教授的说法，布里特头骨和上肢没有受到创伤，
suggested that she might have entered the water at sea level The significant decomposition of Brit's body, coupled with the absence of crucial remains, led to Professor Ranson concluding that neither a time of death or a cause of death could be unequivocally ascertained Although his post-mortem report was significantly more thorough than the first, Ranson ultimately agreed with the results of the Croatian autopsy and ruled the cause of Britlapthorn's death as unknown On October 29, 2008, the police chief in charge of the Britlapthorn investigation, Ivan Kresik, was fired According to a police spokesperson,
这表明她可能是在海平面进入水中的。布里特尸体的严重腐烂，加上关键遗骸的缺失，促使兰森教授得出结论：既无法明确确定死亡时间，也无法明确确定死因。尽管他的尸检报告比第一份彻底得多，但兰森最终同意了克罗地亚尸检的结果，并将布里特·拉普索恩的死因定为“未知”。2008年10月29日，负责布里特·拉普索恩调查的警察局长伊万·克雷西克被解雇。据警方发言人称，
Kresik's termination was part of a new direction for the county's police, designed to curb police inaction The prolonged failings of the Dubrovnik police had been highlighted since the heavily publicized Britlapthorn investigation, with the police spokesperson telling the media, quote We weren't satisfied with the speed of police reaction in the case of Britlapthorn, although the fact remains that she would not have been saved with a faster police reaction Somebody has to take responsibility for the fact that there was a five to six day delay before a serious investigation and quality action was undertaken by leading police
克雷西克的离职是该县警方新方向的一部分，旨在遏制警方的不作为。自广受关注的布里特·拉普索恩调查以来，杜布罗夫尼克警方长期存在的失职行为一直受到关注，警方发言人对媒体表示：“我们对布里特·拉普索恩案中警方反应的速度并不满意，尽管事实仍然是，即使警方反应再快，她也无法得救。必须有人为这样一个事实承担责任，即高级警方在展开认真调查和高质量行动之前，存在五到六天的拖延。”
These internal changes led to a total turnaround in the Dubrovnik police force's conduct regarding the Britlapthorn investigation By November 2008, Dale Lapthorn told the press he felt the languishing investigation was now being fast tracked and believed police efforts had improved outstandingly Key witnesses and the group of backpackers who had been at Club Fuego with Brit on the night of her disappearance had been tracked down and questioned at length Concise credible reports were distributed to the Lapthorns on a weekly basis, keeping the family in the loop of any new developments
这些内部变动导致杜布罗夫尼克警方在处理布里特·拉普索恩调查时的行为发生了彻底的转变。到2008年11月，戴尔·拉普索恩告诉媒体，他觉得拖沓的调查现在正在快进，并相信警方的努力有了显著的改善。关键证人和在布里特失踪当晚与她一起在菲戈俱乐部的一群背包客已被追踪到并接受了详尽的问询。简洁可信的报告每周分发给拉普索恩一家，让这个家庭了解任何新进展。
In a much anticipated move, Dubrovnik police divers finally entered the waters of Bononova Bay to conduct an extensive underwater search for Brit's missing belongings, including her wallet, camera and clothing A police spokesperson claimed the dive mission had been planned long ago but blamed the delay on unfavorable weather conditions Nevertheless, the dive was long overdue for the Lapthorn family, who hoped above all else that Brit's camera would be found, believing it held vital clues as to what happened to her the night she went missing
在一项备受期待的行动中，杜布罗夫尼克警方潜水员终于进入博诺沃湾水域，对布里特失踪的财物（包括她的钱包、相机和衣物）进行了广泛的水下搜寻。警方发言人声称，潜水任务很久以前就计划好了，但将延误归咎于恶劣的天气条件。尽管如此，对于拉普索恩一家来说，这次潜水早就该进行了，他们最希望的是能找到布里特的相机，他们相信相机里藏着关于她失踪当晚发生的事情的至关重要的线索。
However, the divers emerged from the waters of Bononova Bay empty-handed In late December 2008, Dubrovnik police granted the Lapthorn's full access to CCTV footage captured in the vicinity of Club Fuego over the night Brit had attended Although the footage from the club's seven internal security cameras had allegedly been lost due to an electrical fault, an adjacent war memorial was overseen by four high-tech cameras, one of which faced Club Fuego's entrance This camera should have provided clear footage of all persons entering and exiting the venue, but upon being retrieved from the council, it was discovered that this key camera was also
然而，潜水员空手从博诺沃湾的水中浮出水面。2008年12月下旬，杜布罗夫尼克警方批准拉普索恩一家完全访问布里特去过的那个晚上在菲戈俱乐部附近拍摄的闭路电视画面。尽管该俱乐部七个内部安全摄像头的画面据称因电气故障而丢失，但一个邻近的战争纪念碑由四个高科技摄像头监视，其中一个摄像头正对着菲戈俱乐部的入口。这个摄像头本应提供所有进入和离开该场所的人员的清晰画面，但在从市政委员会取回时，人们发现这个关键摄像头也在
dysfunctional between the critical dates of September 17 and 18 The only viable existing footage of Club Fuego was obtained from a council-owned street camera located 50 meters down the road. It didn't provide a direct view of the club's entrance, but did pick up the darkened silhouettes of the few people moving about in the area The grainy footage showed a one-way palm-lined road with Club Fuego on the left and a large block of apartments on the opposite side Dubrovnik police determined that the footage captured nothing of importance Whilst tirelessly reviewing this footage, the Lactorns noted an occurrence at 4.46 am on
9月17日至18日的关键日期之间发生故障。唯一现存可行的菲戈俱乐部画面是由一架位于路边50米处的市政街道摄像机拍摄的。它没有直接拍到俱乐部的入口，但拍到了在当地走动的几个人的黑暗剪影。这段颗粒状的画面显示了一条种满棕榈树的单行道，左边是菲戈俱乐部，对面是一栋大型公寓楼。杜布罗夫尼克警方确定这段画面没有拍到任何重要内容。在不懈审查这段画面的同时，拉普索恩一家注意到9月18日
September 18, when a dark blue van emerged from a side street and came to a stop at the front entrance of Club Fuego. A person exited the club and quickly climbed into the van before it sped off out of shot. Due to the low quality of the dark footage, it was impossible to make out the finer details of the vehicle or identify those inside. But given that Brit was last sighted in the club approximately an hour before the van arrived, the Lactorns considered the unnerving possibility that the figure getting into the vehicle could have been their daughter Their theory was substantiated by a post on an internet forum that had appeared in September, just days after Brit went missing, warning Club Fuego patrons to be on high alert,
凌晨4点46分发生的一件事：一辆深蓝色面包车从一条小街开出，停在菲戈俱乐部的正门前。一个人从俱乐部里出来，迅速爬进面包车，随后面包车加速驶离画面。由于暗色画面的质量较低，无法看清车辆的更多细节或辨认车内人员。但鉴于布里特在面包车到达前大约一小时最后一次被看到在俱乐部里，拉普索恩一家想到了一个令人不安的可能性：上车的那个人可能就是他们的女儿。他们的理论得到了9月份出现在一个互联网论坛上的一篇帖子的证实，该帖子在布里特失踪几天后出现，警告菲戈俱乐部的顾客保持高度警惕，
as two unknown men had been acting menacingly and praying on party goers in the area In a bid to lure young foreign women into their vehicle, the suspicious men claimed to be police officers. The forum post read, quote, a blue van stops, two special police get out, they show their ID and then try and put you in the van. On behalf of Australia's Channel 7 current affairs program Sunday night, veteran investigative reporter Ross Coulthard began independent investigations into the Brit Lapthorn case. Coulthard's inquiries led him to Dubrovnik, where he uncovered an ominous pattern of ingrained criminal activity hidden deep behind the esteemed city's walls. In 2007, an Australian tourist was enjoying a night out
因为有两个身份不明的男子一直在该地区表现出威胁性并以聚会者为猎物。为了引诱年轻的外国女性上车，这些可疑男子自称是警察。论坛帖子写道：“一辆蓝色面包车停下，两个特警出来，他们出示证件，然后试图把你拉进面包车。”代表澳大利亚7号台时事节目《星期日晚》（Sunday Night），资深调查记者罗斯·库尔特哈德开始对布里特·拉普索恩案展开独立调查。库尔特哈德的调查将他带到了杜布罗夫尼克，在那里他揭开了一种隐藏在城市受人尊敬的外墙之深处的险恶的犯罪活动模式。2007年，一名澳大利亚游客在
at Club Fuego when she accepted a ride from two local men driving a dark blue van. When the woman realized she was being driven out of the city and away from her destination, she questioned where they were going, but the men remained silent. Sensing she was in danger, the woman leapt from the moving vehicle and ran down the hillside with the men chasing close behind. Upon reaching a main road, she was rescued by a security guard and taken to hospital, where her ordeal was formally reported to Dubrovnik authorities. In September 2008, an Australian tourist left Club Fuego at around 2am and began the short walk to the harbour where her cruise ship was docked for the night. Suddenly, a dark blue van
菲戈俱乐部享受夜生活时，接受了两个当地男子的搭车邀请，他们开着一辆深蓝色面包车。当这名女子意识到自己被载着驶离城市、远离目的地时，她质问他们要去哪里，但两名男子保持沉默。意识到自己处于危险之中，这名女子从行驶中的车辆中跳了下来，顺着山坡逃跑，两名男子紧追不舍。到达大马路后，她被一名保安救下并送往医院，她的遭遇正式报告给了杜布罗夫尼克当局。2008年9月，一名澳大利亚游客在凌晨2点左右离开菲戈俱乐部，开始步行前往邮轮当晚停泊的港口。突然，一辆深蓝色面包车
carrying several men accelerated towards her. A passenger hanging out the open side door attempted to pull the woman into the vehicle, but she escaped, taking refuge in an isolated area away from the road. Seemingly out of nowhere, a group of 5-7 armed men emerged and crowded around her, chanting, police, police. She immediately recognized one of the men as the passenger in the blue van who had tried to snatch her moments earlier. The woman's friends rushed to help, causing the group of men to scatter. This incident occurred just five days before Britlapthorn vanished, and it was reported to both the Australian Federal Police and Dubrovnik officials.
载着几个人向她加速驶来。一名探出敞开的侧门的乘客试图将这名女子拉进车里，但她逃脱了，躲在一个远离道路的孤立区域。仿佛凭空出现一样，一周围着5-7名武装男子的群体出现并围在她身边，高呼“警察，警察”。她立刻认出其中一名男子就是几分钟前试图绑架她的蓝色面包车上的乘客。这名女子的朋友赶来帮忙，导致这群男子四散奔逃。这起事件发生在布里特·拉普索恩失踪前仅仅五天，并且已向澳大利亚联邦警察和杜布罗夫尼克官员报案。
In the following month of October 2008, an American tourist was approached by two local men inside Club Fuego who flashed what appeared to be a police badge. They told the woman she was under arrest and demanded she leave with them immediately. When she refused, the pair proceeded to beat up her male companion. Other nightclub patrons intervened, and the attackers fled the club in the company of several other men. This occurred just 10 days after Britlapthorn's disappearance. In another incident, a solo female tourist disembarked a bus at 3am in Dubrovnik's western port area, a short walk from Club Fuego. She was talking on her mobile phone when a group of men circled her, flashing a badge and claiming to be police officers.
在接下来的2008年10月，一名美国游客在菲戈俱乐部内遭到两名当地男子的接近，他们闪现了看起来像是警察徽章的东西。他们告诉这名女子她被捕了，并要求她马上跟他们走。当她拒绝时，两人开始殴打她的男性同伴。其他夜总会顾客进行了干预，袭击者在几个其他男子的陪伴下逃离了俱乐部。这发生在布里特·拉普索恩失踪仅仅10天之后。在另一起事件中，一名独自一人的女性游客在凌晨3点在杜布罗夫尼克西部港口区下车，距离菲戈俱乐部只有一小段步行路程。她正在用手机通话，这时一群男子围住了她，闪现徽章并声称自己是警察。
The group of men fled when a local stepped in to assist the woman. The women targeted shared similar characteristics. They were all female, young, blonde, slim, and foreign, all features matching those of Britlapthorn. Although minor details of their ordeals varied, they were all confronted in or near Club Fuego by at least two local men claiming to be police officers. The perpetrators used a distinctive dark blue van, the same type of vehicle caught on CCTV footage pulling up to Club Fuego around the time Britlapthorn vanished. Dubrovnik law enforcement initially denied knowledge of these alleged abductions, but were forced to backtrack and accept awareness when Ross Coulthart presented them with official
当一名当地人介入协助这名女子时，这群男子逃跑了。这些成为目标的女性有着相似的特征：她们都是女性、年轻、金发、苗条、外国籍，所有特征都与布里特·拉普索恩相符。尽管她们遭遇的微小细节各不相同，但她们都在菲戈俱乐部内部或附近遭到至少两名自称是警察的当地男子的对质。行凶者使用了一辆独特的深蓝色面包车，这与在布里特·拉普索恩失踪前后停在菲戈俱乐部外的闭路电视画面上捕捉到的车辆类型相同。杜布罗夫尼克执法部门最初否认知道这些所谓的绑架事件，但在罗斯·库尔特哈德向他们出示了在其中两起事件后汇编的官方
reports compiled after two of the incidents. One was a report sent to Dubrovnik law enforcement by the Australian federal police after they were contacted by a survivor. The other was a medical report collected from the hospital one of the other survivors attended after her ordeal, detailing the circumstances of her visit. Despite these reports indicating the perpetrators were masquerading as police officers, no action had been taken to identify or apprehend the suspects. In early February 2009, Ross Coulthart's incriminating findings into the Britlapthorn case were broadcasted on Channel 7's Sunday Night program. Identicated images of the two main perpetrators were created based on descriptions provided by survivors. One was tall, with short,
报告后，他们被迫改口并承认知情。其中一份是由澳大利亚联邦警察在接到幸存者联系后发送给杜布罗夫尼克执法部门的报告。另一份是从其中一名其他幸存者在遭遇劫难后就诊的医院收集的医疗报告，详细说明了她就医的情况。尽管这些报告表明肇事者在冒充警察，但没有采取任何行动来识别或逮捕嫌疑人。2009年2月初，罗斯·库尔特哈德对布里特·拉普索恩案的定罪调查结果在7号台的《星期日晚》节目中播出。根据幸存者提供的描述，制作了两名主要肇事者的肖像。其中一人个子高，留着短而
dusty blonde hair, a pale complexion, small face, narrow nose and large ears. The second was shorter and had a square shaped face with cropped dark hair, heavy eyebrows, dark eyes and a tanned complexion. Sunday Night's deeming expose quickly garnered the curiosity of the Australian media and public. Open to the possibility Britlapthorn had been a victim of a well-established criminal gang posing as the Dubrovnik police. The identity kits of the two alleged ringleaders were widely circulated and in a confounding revelation, it was quickly discovered that the suspect's sketches closely resembled two active Dubrovnik police officers. Croatian authorities were quick to hold a press conference addressing the accusations,
尘土般的金色头发，肤色苍白，脸小，鼻子窄，耳朵大。第二个个子较矮，有一张方形的脸，留着修剪过的黑发，浓眉大眼，肤色较黑。《星期日晚》的这篇曝光迅速引起了澳大利亚媒体和公众的好奇。人们对布里特·拉普索恩可能是假冒杜布罗夫尼克警察的成熟犯罪团伙的受害者持开放态度。这两名据称是团伙头目的身份拼图被广泛流传，在一个令人困惑的发现中，人们很快发现嫌疑人的草图与两名现役杜布罗夫尼克警察极为相似。克罗地亚当局迅速召开新闻发布会，应对这些指控，
but instead of their usual hard-lined denial approach, they accepted the identity kits matched the appearance of two members of Dubrovnik's local police. This revelation opened many questions, but the spokesperson didn't dwell on the validity of the claims, instead assuring reporters that the unnamed officers in question were exemplary members of law enforcement. Croatian publication National revealed the identities of the two police officers at the centre of the allegations, with other news sources quickly following suit. Ivica Rudinovich and a dragon Palomeda were both married fathers who worked alongside one another in Dubrovnik's narcotic squad, harboring varying reputations within the force.
但他们没有采取通常的强硬否认态度，而是接受了身份拼图与杜布罗夫尼克当地警察的两名成员外表相符的事实。这一启示引发了许多问题，但发言人没有在说法的有效性上纠缠，而是向记者保证，所涉的未具名警官是执法部门的模范成员。克罗地亚出版物《国家》披露了处于指控中心的这两名警察的身份，其他新闻来源也迅速跟进。伊维察·鲁迪诺维奇和德拉贡·帕洛梅达都是已婚父亲，他们在杜布罗夫尼克的缉毒小队里并肩工作，在警队中有着不同的声誉。
Whilst the dragon Palomeda was a long-serving officer with a clean record, Ivica Rudinovich's reputation was marred by an undisclosed disciplinary procedure that resulted in a severe demotion from the coveted special police force to beat Kopp. The integrity of Rudinovich was considered dubious, as it was rumoured the officer had intentionally lied during an investigation in order to clear colleagues of assault charges made against them. During each of the alleged abduction attempts, Ivica Rudinovich and a dragon Palomeda were rusted on patrol duty together. Dressed in plain clothes, the pair surveyed Dubrovnik's night spots as part of narcotic reduction efforts. They didn't deny confronting foreign
虽然德拉贡·帕洛梅达是一名资深警察且记录清白，但伊维察·鲁迪诺维奇的声誉却因一起未公开的纪律处分而受损，该处分导致他从令人艳羡的特警部队被严重降职为巡警。鲁迪诺维奇的诚实度受到质疑，因为有传言称，这名警官在调查过程中故意撒谎，以洗清同事受到的殴打指控。在每一次所谓的绑架企图中，伊维察·鲁迪诺维奇和德拉贡·帕洛梅达都在一起值勤巡逻。两人身穿便服，作为减少毒品行动的一部分，在杜布罗夫尼克的夜生活场所进行搜查。他们没有否认在值勤期间在菲戈俱乐部内外与外国
women in and around Club Fuego whilst on duty, but maintained any interactions were purely part of their undercover drug operations. Meanwhile, a search to locate the crucial dark blue van revealed there was one vehicle registered in Dubrovnik to fit the description, a Volkswagen Charan multi-purpose vehicle used by the Dubrovnik police force. Zlatko Sikola had recently replaced Ivan Kresik as Dubrovnik's police chief and was working tirelessly to make positive progress on the mishandled Britlapthorn investigation. If there was any truth to the allegations that fellow police officers were involved in the abduction and assault of foreign women, Sikola knew he'd struggled to get to the bottom of the
女性对质，但坚称任何互动纯粹是他们卧底毒品行动的一部分。与此同时，寻找关键深蓝色面包车的搜寻显示，杜布罗夫尼克注册了一辆符合描述的车辆：一辆大众夏朗多功能车，由杜布罗夫尼克警察部队使用。兹拉特科·西科拉最近取代伊万·库尔克里卡成为杜布罗夫尼克警察局长，并正在孜孜不倦地努力在被错误处理的布里特·拉普索恩调查中取得积极进展。如果关于同行警察参与绑架和袭击外国女性的指控有任何真实性，西科拉知道他将很难查清
matter. The reputation of the Dubrovnik police force was tainted by lingering rumors of corruption and cover-ups, with residents perceiving their city as a place where organised crime thrived. Accusations that terminated police chief Ivan Kresik had either underestimated, ignored, or tacitly tolerated. Dedicated to restoring the reputation of the Dubrovnik police force and eradicating any disgraced officers, police chief Sikola made a brash and shocking move, relieving 70% of command personnel from duty. Despite the tenacious efforts employed by police chief Sikola to clear Dubrovnik's tarnished police force and renew the investigation into Britlapthorn's unresolved death, years
事情的真相。杜布罗夫尼克警察局的声誉因挥之不去的腐败和掩盖丑闻的传言而受到玷污，居民们将他们的城市视为有组织犯罪蓬勃发展的地方。针对被解职的警察局长伊万·库尔克里卡低估、忽视或默许这些行为的指控。为了恢复杜布罗夫尼克警察局的声誉并铲除任何声名狼藉的警察，警察局长西科拉采取了鲁莽而令人震惊的举动，解除70%的指挥人员的职务。尽管警察局长西科拉为洗清杜布罗夫尼克受玷污的警察局并重启对布里特·拉普索恩未解死亡之谜的调查付出了顽强努力，但几年过去了，
passed with virtually no fresh information coming to light. Seven years after Britlapthorn's body was found in Bononovo Bay, hopes of finding a resolution to the mystery were renewed when Victorian state coroner Ian Gray was tasked with holding a coronial inquest into the 21-year-old's death. All available evidence, leads, reports, and witness statements relating to the Britlapthorn investigation were compiled and scrutinised during the inquest, and in April 2015 Ian Gray presented his findings in the Victorian Coroner's Court. Coroner Gray concluded the following facts. Between midnight and 12.30 a.m. on September 18, 2008, Britlapthorn arrived by bus the club Fuego with a group of backpackers after consuming an unverified quantity of alcohol. There,
几乎没有新的信息浮出水面。在布里特·拉普索恩的尸体在博诺沃湾被发现七年后，当维多利亚州验尸官伊恩·格雷被委任对这名21岁女子的死因进行验尸研讯时，解开这个谜团的希望重新燃起。在研讯期间，收集并仔细审查了与布里特·拉普索恩调查相关的所有可用证据、线索、报告和证人证言，2015年4月，伊恩·格雷在维多利亚验尸法院公布了他的调查结果。格雷验尸官总结了以下事实：2008年9月18日午夜至凌晨12点30分之间，布里特·拉普索恩在消耗了未知数量的酒精后，与一群背包客乘巴士抵达菲戈俱乐部。在那里，
Brit continued to consume alcohol and became heavily intoxicated. She was last seen in the club between 3 and 3.30 a.m. Her remains were located 18 days later in Bononovo Bay on October 6, 2008. No further facts could be unequivocally as it paint. Dubrovnik police claimed their investigations into the young Australian's death involved over 500 interviews with potential witnesses, polygraph examinations, execution of multiple search warrants, and retrieval of data from mobile phone towers during the critical time period between September 17 and 18, 2008. The Australian federal police had since conducted an inquiry into Dubrovnik law enforcement's handling of the case, and found police were,
布里特继续饮酒，变得酩酊大醉。她最后一次被人看到是在凌晨3点到3点30分之间的俱乐部里。18天后的2008年10月6日，她的遗体在博诺诺沃湾被找到。由于情况复杂，无法确凿得出进一步的结论。杜布罗夫尼克警方声称，他们对这位年轻澳大利亚女子死因的调查涉及对潜在目击者的500多次访谈、测谎仪检查、多次搜查令的执行，以及在2008年9月17日至18日这一关键时期提取手机信号塔数据。此后，澳大利亚联邦警察对杜布罗夫尼克执法部门对该案的处理情况进行了调查，并发现警方……
quote, professional and determined in their efforts. The coroner acknowledged that while there were several deficiencies in the initial treatment of Brit's disappearance, Dubrovnik police had since exhausted all available avenues during their ongoing investigations. The possibility that Brit had fallen victim to the same gang of local men who had attempted to abduct several other young female travelers during their time in Dubrovnik was disputed by coroner Gray, who determined, quote, there was no evidence or information found indicating the attacks on the women were linked to each other or to Brit's death. However, the coroner was able to resolve one lingering theory, quote. Based on evidence, there is no reason or basis to
引用原话，在他们的努力中表现专业且坚定。验尸官承认，虽然在最初处理布里特失踪事件时存在一些不足，但杜布罗夫尼克警方在随后的持续调查中已经用尽了所有可用的途径。关于布里特成为当地同一帮男子的受害者的可能性，这伙人曾在杜布罗夫尼克逗留期间试图绑架其他几名年轻女性游客，验尸官格雷对这一说法提出了异议，他断定，引用原话，没有找到任何证据或信息表明针对这些女性的袭击彼此相关，也与布里特的死无关。然而，验尸官得以解决一个挥之不去的理论，引用原话。根据证据，没有任何理由或根据……
conclude that Brit at any time acted with the intention of ending her own life, by therefore conclude that her death was due to either accident or foul play. When it came to the exact cause of Brit's death, coroner Gray officially ruled. The evidence does not support a finding as to when or how Brit's death occurred. I therefore formally find that the cause or causes of Brit Lapthorn's death remain unassetained. Dale Lapthorn addressed the court on behalf of his family, thanking them for their efforts in attempting to establish the truth about what happened to his daughter. Although the Lapthorn family would continue to seek answers, Dale admitted they had come to terms with the fact they may never know for sure how Brit lost her life. One positive
得出结论认为布里特在任何时候都有结束自己生命的意图，因此得出结论，她的死是由于意外或谋杀。至于布里特死亡的确切原因，验尸官格雷做出了官方裁决。证据不支持关于布里特死亡发生的时间或方式的认定。因此，我正式裁定布里特·拉普索恩的死因仍然不明。戴尔·拉普索恩代表他的家人在法庭上发言，感谢他们为查明他女儿身上发生的事情真相所做出的努力。尽管拉普索恩一家将继续寻求答案，但戴尔承认，他们已经接受了这样一个事实：他们可能永远无法确切知道布里特是如何失去生命的。
Dale took from the overwhelming tragedy was that Brit's death had created a legacy that compelled other young backpackers to be more cautious when traveling overseas. The realization that his daughter's case prompted dramatic changes in the leadership and practices of Dubrovnik's problematic law enforcement was also a source of comfort for Dale, quote. I don't like saying this, but maybe she didn't die in vain. Outside court, Brit's older brother Darren told the media it had been a tough seven years and stated, although we may never really find out what happened to Brit, I know I still live in the hope that one day, as long as I live, I'll find out an answer. One day, someone will need to
戴尔从这场巨大的悲剧中获得的一个积极方面是，布里特的死留下了遗产，迫使其他年轻的背包客在海外旅行时更加谨慎。意识到女儿的案子促成了杜布罗夫尼克问题重重的执法部门领导层和做法发生戏剧性变化，这也是戴尔感到安慰的一个来源，引用原话。我不想这么说，但也许她没有白死。在法庭外，布里特的哥哥达伦对媒体表示，这艰难的七年过去了，并表示，尽管我们可能永远无法真正弄清楚布里特身上发生了什么，但我知道我仍然怀着希望，有一天，只要我活着，我就会找到答案。总有一天，会有人需要……
clear their conscience. There was a sentiment shared by his mother, Elka, quote. Whoever did this to our daughter, they have to live with their guilt. I hope it tortures them like we're tortured every day. But in the end, nothing we do will bring our daughter back to us. Our feeling is, we've just had to learn to live with it. Upon the conclusion of the coroner's inquest, Dubrovnik law enforcement have since conceded it was highly unlikely that Brit Lapthorne took her own life, or voluntarily entered the waters of Bononovo Bay prior to her death. Although the case is still considered an ongoing criminal investigation, Croatian authorities surmise Brit's death was the result of misadventure.
求得内心安宁。他的母亲埃尔卡也有同感，引用原话。无论谁对我们的女儿做出这种事，他们都必须带着内疚生活。我希望它折磨他们，就像我们每天被折磨一样。但到头来，我们做任何事都无法让我们的女儿回到我们身边。我们的感觉是，我们不得不学会接受它。在验尸官研讯结束之际，杜布罗夫尼克执法部门此后承认，布里特·拉普索恩极不可能自杀，或者在死前自愿进入博诺诺沃湾的水域。尽管该案仍被认为是一起正在进行的刑事调查，但克罗地亚当局推测布里特的死是遭遇不幸的结果。
It's a conclusion the Lapthorne's have always disagreed with, certain Brit was murdered. Many aspects of the case remain unexplained or unresolved, including the identity of the person seen on CCTV footage getting into the blue van outside Club Fuego, the purpose of the 2.57 AM call made from Brit's mobile phone the morning of her disappearance, the whereabouts of her wallet and Canon PowerShot G9 camera, and what caused the considerable damage sustained to Brit's recovered remains. Although suspicion has been cast on a range of people over the years, including the backpackers who attended Club Fuego with Brit, the manager of the Dubrovnik Backpackers Club hostel Avica Perkovich, and the Dubrovnik police officers accused of attempting
拉普索恩一家一直不同意这个结论，他们坚信布里特是被谋杀的。案件的许多方面仍未得到解释或解决，包括在Fuego俱乐部外上了一辆蓝色面包车的闭路电视监控录像上看到的人的身份，布里特失踪那天早上她手机打出的凌晨2点57分电话的目的，她的钱包和佳能PowerShot G9相机的下落，以及是什么原因导致布里特找回的遗体受到相当大的破坏。尽管这些年来对各种各样的人产生了怀疑，包括与布里特一起去Fuego俱乐部的背包客、杜布罗夫尼克背包客俱乐部旅舍经理阿维卡·佩科维奇，以及被指控企图……
to abduct female tourists. There are no formal suspects in the case. Media coverage of the case has since waned, but the general consensus from the Australian press and public supports the theory that Brit was abducted and killed. Dale Lapthorne, quote, As to whether we will ever find out what happened to Brit, I'm not sure. But we gave it everything. What we did is, we gave it our best shot. She was our daughter. We loved her. We still do. What more can I say? We tried. To cope with the pain of their daughter's unresolved death, Dale and Delka Lapthorne focus on the many happy memories they have of Brit.
绑架女游客的杜布罗夫尼克警官。此案没有正式的嫌疑人。此案的媒体报道此后有所减弱，但澳大利亚媒体和公众的普遍共识支持布里特被绑架和杀害的理论。戴尔·拉普索恩，引用原话，至于我们是否能找到布里特身上发生了什么，我不确定。但我们付出了全部。我们所做的是，我们尽了最大努力。她是我们的女儿。我们爱她。我们依然爱她。我还能说什么？我们尽力了。为了应对女儿未解死因带来的痛苦，戴尔和德尔卡·拉普索恩将注意力集中在他们对布里特的许多美好回忆上。
For a long time afterwards, her bedroom was kept just as it was when she departed for her big solo European adventure. And sometimes, Dale would sit in Brit's old subcar, listening to her favorite CDs. He holds on to the small reminders he has of his daughter, including the final text message she sent to him just days before her disappearance, which simply read, Happy Birthday, Dad. Thousands of photographs chronicling Brit's travels across the world are safely stored on a hard drive, which her family look at often, grateful there are so many. The photo Dale holds most dear is the last image he took of his daughter in Paris on her 21st birthday, a memory he will always remember with overwhelming fondness.
在那之后的很长一段时间里，她的卧室保持着她启程去进行独自的欧洲大冒险时的原样。有时，戴尔会坐在布里特的旧车里，听她最喜欢的CD。他紧紧抓住留下的关于女儿的少许纪念品，包括她在失踪前几天发给他的最后一条短信，上面简单地写着：“生日快乐，爸爸。”记录了布里特世界各地旅行的数千张照片被安全地存放在硬盘上，她的家人经常翻看，庆幸有这么多照片。戴尔最珍视的照片是他在布里特21岁生日那天在巴黎拍下的女儿的最后一张照片，这个记忆他将永远带着无尽的喜爱去铭记。
Years after Brit's death, Dale retraced his daughter's final journey by embarking on his own solo backpacking trip through Europe. For the grieving father, the profound experience delivered a sense of comfort as though Brit was alongside him every step of the way. He boarded the same trains, visited the same landmarks, and ate at the same restaurants Brit had, relishing the landscapes she had once described as the best places she had ever seen. Elka Lapthorne has not bit her daughter goodbye, but instead, off feet is in, a German expression meaning, until we see each other again. Despite the high-profile nature of the Brit Lapthorne case, the Brovnik has successfully maintained its reputation as a safe travel destination. An endless flow of tourists continue
在布里特去世多年后，戴尔通过踏上自己的欧洲独自背包旅行，重走了女儿最后一段旅程。对于这位悲伤的父亲来说，这段深刻的体验带来了一种慰藉，仿佛布里特一路都在陪伴着他。他坐上同样的火车，参观同样的地标，在布里特去过的同一家餐馆吃饭，细细品味着她曾经形容为她见过最美地方的风景。埃尔卡·拉普索恩并没有跟女儿说再见，而是说了一个德语表达，意思是，直到我们再次相见。尽管布里特·拉普索恩案备受瞩目，但杜布罗夫尼克成功保持了其作为安全旅游目的地的声誉。源源不断的游客继续……
to visit the medieval city each year, further popularized for being one of the main filming locations for the fictional city of King's Landing in the HBO television series Game of Thrones. Club Fuego's reputation was irreparably tarnished following accusations the thriving night spot was a hotbed for sleazy criminal activity. Eventually, the nightclub underwent a complete rebranding and successfully re-established itself as a popular tourist hangout, which remains in operation today. Back in late September 2008, the owner of Club Fuego, Vinko Cosmire, observed the Australian media swarming outside his premises. Their intimidating presence deterring the club's usual revelers and leaving it uncharacteristically empty. Cosmire lifted himself off his bar stall
每年造访这座中世纪城市，由于它是HBO电视剧《权力的游戏》中虚构城市君临的主要拍摄地之一，其知名度进一步提高。由于有指控称这个繁荣的夜生活场所是肮脏犯罪活动的温床，Fuego俱乐部的声誉受到了不可挽回的玷污。最终，这家夜总会经历了一次彻底的品牌重塑，成功重塑了自己作为热门旅游聚集地的地位，至今仍在运营。回到2008年9月下旬，Fuego俱乐部的主人温科·科斯米尔注意到澳大利亚媒体蜂拥至他的店外。他们令人生畏的出现在俱乐部里吓退了平时的狂欢者，使其显得空无一人。科斯米尔从酒吧凳子上站了起来，……
and invited the reporters into his establishment, telling them, You from Australia have taught us a good lesson. You lose one Australian and you care. You send people to find her. You press the police to really do something. It is a good example for us, Australians caring. When we suffered the war, nobody tried to see what happened, to look for people we could learn. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并邀请记者进入他的店铺，对他们说，你们澳大利亚人给我们上了一课。你们失去了一个澳大利亚人，你们在乎。你们派人去寻找她。你们向警方施压，让他们真正做点什么。这是我们学习的好榜样，澳大利亚人是有爱心的。当我们遭受战争时，没有人试图去看看发生了什么，去寻找我们可以了解的人。这集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。